Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und hier ist na.
Hier ist äh UKW
Corona-Wikli, die einundfünfzigste Ausgabe von Corona Wickli und natürlich die siebenundsiebzigste Ausgabe von UKW, weil gibt's ja auch noch andere Themen, auch wenn das alles sehr coronalastig äh noch ist, noch, noch ist es so. Ich hoffe, es bleibt nicht so lange
So oder so äh es ist Freitag und ich bin nicht alleine, sondern natürlich gibt's auch noch den Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Und gemeinsam versuchen wir, wie ihr es gewohnt seid, hier so ein bisschen, tja, so ein bisschen die Essenz aus all dem herauszulotsen, was uns so äh Corona-Krisenmäßig an Nachrichten umgibt,
Ja und ähm diese Woche glaube ich müssen wir uns ein bisschen zurückhalten, nicht zu optimistisch zu werden. Oder?
Ja
Also ich meine, waren wir ja in der letzten Woche auch äh schon nicht und,
um es gleich mal vorwegzunehmen äh die Zahlen
sinken weiter, auch wenn äh sagen, gestern
vorgestern so ein kleiner Schreck eingetreten ist, weil der R-Wert äh plötzlich innerhalb von einem Tag um äh null Komma eins.
Angestiegen ist, mehr als um null Komma.
Eins angestiegen ist und da war dann halt ein bisschen unklar, okay, ist das jetzt weder die Trendwende hin zu steigenden Zahlen, aber heute äh hatten wir dann, beziehungsweise mit den,
vom gestrigen äh Tag, also von Mitternacht hatten wir dann wieder jetzt einen kleinen Rückgang äh beim R-Wert, also das und der ist immer noch.
Unter eins äh aktuell deutschlandweit null Komma acht vier der sieben Tage R-Wert
und das ist jetzt nicht mehr so schön wie der null Komma siebener R-Wert, den wir noch äh vor zwei Tagen,
aber ist jetzt auch noch kein Weltuntergang.
Vor allem sind wir jetzt, glaube ich, grade so, also eigentlich wären wir jetzt so in dem Bereich, wo es sich wieder ausgleicht.
Das Pfingstwochenende konkret, weil das war ja ein bisschen der Auslöser. Wir hatten halt Pfingsten und ähm damit dann eben ein Pfingstmontag und das hat so
allerlei durcheinander gebracht bei den Impfzahlen sieht das ja nicht sehr viel anders aus. Und heute hätte man sagen können,
Heute hätte es sich eigentlich so spätestens rausschütteln müssen, nur jetzt kommt ja dann mit Frohnleichnam nochmal so ein zwei Drittel Feiertag mit dazu, also zwei Drittel, weil nur zwei Drittel der deutschen Beferkerung Feiertag haben und der Rest nicht.
Und ja dann läuft wieder alles so ein bisschen auseinander und das ist immer so ein typischer Effekt, ne, da hast du so einen Feiertag in der Woche und dann.
Greifen diese ganzen sieben Tagesbetrachtungen, diese ganzen sieben Tagesmittel, die ja normalerweise das.
Wochengeschehen ganz gut abfedern. Die greifen dann halt nicht mehr und dann gibt's so Nachholeffekte und dann kann halt auch mal irgendwas hochgehen, was eigentlich gar nicht hochgehen sollte.
Genau, also im Grunde genommen, äh weil das auch mal die.
Die Frage war, wenn man sich so die täglichen Zahlen anguckt, dann schwingen die Prinzip als als Kurve so. Es gibt halt einen Maximum und ein Minimum und das liegt,
extrem weit auseinander meistens so, dass das Maximum ist in der Regel mittwochs und äh ja, das äh Minimum ist es ist eben meistens montags
und deswegen äh ja, wenn man, wenn man eben jetzt die sieben Tage nimmt und da ist dann ein Feiertag mit drin, dann ähm,
ändert sich quasi die ja Frequenz erstmal, beziehungsweise die Phase dieser Kurve und dann ähm
ja, hat man dann in den in den sieben Tagen unter Umständen in den letzten sieben Tagen dann eben mehr Feiertage drin und deswegen ändert sich dann
halt auch ja die sieben Tage Inzidenz und wenn dann die nächste Woche,
sagen wieder kommt, wo sich das dann normalisiert hat, dann sieht man wieder, dass das Gegenteil, dann sieht man eben wieder plötzlich in den, in den Zahlen, je nachdem, wann der Feiertag so war, sieht man dann eben wieder einen einen leichten Anstieg der,
Das ist aber alles nicht real, sondern sind quasi Sampling Artifakte, wenn man wenn man so will, äh die wir, die wir da sehen.
Sampling Art Effect. Christliche Sampling Artifakte.
Mhm. Der genau christlichen Logistikfunktion.
Ja. Dann würde ich doch einfach vorschlagen, schauen wir uns doch mal die Zahlen mal äh genau an, um mal so ein bisschen zu ergründen, was eigentlich genau grade so passiert.
Ja. Ähm gut, was was passiert,
Wir haben jetzt immer noch im Prinzip seit ja seit Anfang Mai äh haben ja die Inzidenzen dann sehr schnell zu fallen äh begonnen und äh auch,
der R-Wert ist immer weiter zurückgegangen oder fast immer
immer weiter zurückgegangen mit so ein paar kleinen Feiertagsschwankungen, die sich da natürlich auch auch niederschlagen
und wir sind jetzt Deutschland weit beinahe Inzidenz jener also nach Publikationstag von äh dreißig Komma eins an äh gekommen
so pro hunderttausend. Ähm ja, was,
jetzt, ich sage mal, früher äh wäre das irgendwie alles immer noch äh wären das Hochrisiko,
Zonen gewesen.
Wir erinnern uns, Berlin über zwanzig, oh mein Gott, können wir überhaupt noch nach Berlin fahren irgendwie, in diesen Seuchen Herd?
Ab fünfzig ging's nicht mehr in die Schweiz.
Und gut es hat sich, das setze ich jetzt alles offenbar so ein bisschen relativiert in den, in den Köpfen und.
Auch äh vielleicht daher, weil sich die dunkelziffern so verändert haben, auch durchs durchs Test Regime gegenüber der der ersten Welle, ich mal ausgerechnet.
Hatten wir so äh jetzt.
Durch durch mehr Tests eher so anderthalb zwischen anderthalb und zweimal,
höhere äh oder höhere Dunkelziffer und dementsprechend äh niedrigere Inzidenz äh ausgewiesen im Vergleich zur tatsächlichen.
Infektionsausbreitung. So, wenn man also vergleicht.
Frühere Inzidenzen oder spätere Inzidenzen oder auch Inzidenzen in Bundesländern woanders getestet wird, so Bayern, zum Beispiel, hat halt ein sehr gutes äh Test,
Regime oder Testregime, wo sich im Prinzip jeder leicht testen lassen kann, andere Bundesländer sind da deutlich restriktiver
und äh auch andere Länder in Europa testen halt wesentlich mehr, sodass man eben bei Inzidenzvergleichen
zwischen auch verschiedenen Regionen immer gucken muss, das kann man in der Regel nicht alles eins zu eins vergleichen, sondern
im Vergleich zu England beispielsweise auch wenn sich dort jetzt die offiziellen Inzidenzen kreuzen, wird in England sehr viel mehr getestet, so dass man sagen kann, dass das in England die Dunkelziffern
niedriger ist als bei uns. Wenn dann die offiziellen Zahlen gleich sind, äh liegt die Inzidenz in England wahrscheinlich deutlich unter der von Deutschland wegen des.
Regimes sein.
Was haben wir noch? Ja, die Zahl äh der Todesfälle ist jetzt glücklicherweise pro Woche unter tausend gesunken. Allerdings.
Ist die längst nicht so zurückgegangen bisher wie die Inzidenzen zurückgegangen sind, wobei.
Man da dann in der Regel auch, also um Inzidenzvergleiche machen zu müssen, kann man äh oder.
So rum, die, wenn man die Sterblichkeit betrachtet,
muss man äh immer auf die Altersgruppen schauen, weil fünfundsiebzig Prozent der Toten gehen auf die äh kommen aus der.
Altersgruppe achtzig plus und dann nochmal weitere, wenn ich fünfzehn bis zwanzig Prozent von sechzig bis neunundsiebzig und,
alles darunter macht halt eh nur fünf Prozent aus, das heißt ehm wenn dann vor allem jüngere unter sechzig erkranken hat das jetzt nicht so viel Auswirkungen dann eh auf die Zahl der Todesfälle,
und ja, aber ich finde, achthundertvierzig Todesfälle ist.
Immer noch ziemlich hoch pro Woche. Also ich, ja. Das sind ungefähr hundert, hundert am.
Oder über hundert pro Tag und das ist natürlich nicht nicht schön.
Aber es fällt zumindest. Also wir haben durch die Bank fallende Zahlen, wir haben fallende Zahlen bei Intensivstationen, wir haben fallende Zahlen bei den Toten, wir haben fallende Zahlen beim.
Bei der Inzidenz und ja der könnte.
Könnt ihr gerne auch noch ein bisschen äh fallen so. Ich fand das sehr schön, als mal so auf null Komma sieben zwei war und wie sie auf einmal alle so gewundert haben, ja warum fallen denn die Zahlen so schnell.
Ja
Das kann doch gar nicht sein.
Genau dieses das ist sozusagen das ist das Umgekehrte, sozusagen Erstaunen, dass äh exponentielles das ist nicht nur exponentielles Wachstum gibt, sondern eben auch ein exponentiellen Rückgang
und äh ja und bei null Komma sieben hatten wir ja fast eine Halbierung der Zahlen pro Woche.
Ja und.
Zehn Tagen waren's dann.
Und da kommt man natürlich dann dann sehr schnell auch auch nach unten. Das ist ja das, was wir die ganze Zeit äh propagiert haben.
Hört aber keiner zu. Wie das so ist, ne?
Ja, mhm.
Und ja, wenn man sich dann nochmal anguckt, wie das denn jetzt so in den, in den Altersgruppen aussieht, dann gibt's da gerade nicht allzu viele.
Auffälligkeiten, die,
marschieren mehr oder weniger im im Gleichtakt grade die die Altersgruppen. Es gibt da jetzt keine Ausreißer oder keine Altersgruppe, die im Moment ausschert, wo man sagen könnte, so wie
Anfang äh des Jahres zum Beispiel als dann plötzlich oder beziehungsweise,
ab Februar als dann plötzlich die Inzidenzen bei den Kindern so bis vierzehn wird sich von.
Niedrigsten Inzidenzen um die fünfzig auf
ja bei den bei der Gruppe der Schüler auf über zweihundertfünfzig angestiegen ist und alle anderen Altersgruppen quasi überholt hat. So. Sowas haben wir äh im Moment nicht, sondern
Altersgruppen ja Altersgruppen laufen parallel und.
Dementsprechend auch, also gucken wir mal auf die auch gerne auf, zu sagen pseudor Werte in den Altersgruppen.
In dem einfach dieselbe Rechnung, die für die R-Wertberechnung herangezogen wird. Für alle Altersgruppen getrennt mache.
Und da sieht man auch, dass die.
Im Gleichtakt marschieren, wobei sich da sehr schön zeigt, der Impfeffekt.
So dass nämlich die Altersgruppe achtzig plus und sechzig bis neunundsiebzig die niedrigsten pseudor Werte.
Aufweist, während ja, die Kinder die Höchsten haben, weil.
Vermutlich die Impfquote praktisch bei null liegt bei den bei den Kindern, während sie eben bei ja achtzig Plus am höchsten liegt
Aber interessant ist auch da, dass die nur den Altersgruppen um null Komma eins auseinander liegen, also.
Moment bei den bei achtzig plus sind's null Komma sieben sechs und bei.
Jetzt den den Schülern und den Kindern ist das äh null Komma acht acht. Äh die nehmen sich da gerade nicht nicht viel und der Rest liegt so dazwischen.
Ähm und dann vielleicht noch einen Blick auf die Bundesländer.
Da sieht man jetzt ganz schön, während die in der letzten Welle alle ziemlich auseinander.
Gelaufen sind, also sehr weit gespreizt waren und es hm ja mit hm und es dann mit,
zum Beispiel Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, aber hauptsächlich Schleswig-Holstein war so eine
niedrig Inzidenzregion die ganze Zeit über und äh umgekehrt auf der anderen Seite waren's dann Sachsen und Thüringen, wobei sich jetzt Sachsen.
Ganz gut,
äh Thüringen ganz gut entwickelt hat, Sachsen ist jetzt im Moment auf Platz zwei und Spitzenreiter grade ist aber Baden-Württemberg bei den, bei den Inzidenzen, aber ganz knapp vor Sachsen und Hessen und im Saarland.
Also sind die Unterschiede schon signifikant teilweise.
Also im Moment Mecklenburg-Vorpommern liegt jetzt bei elfeinhalb und Baden-Württemberg so noch bei achtunddreißig, neununddreißig ungefähr.
Mhm. Und das ist ja auch bei den Ehrwerten so, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern einfach noch einen extrem niedrigen äh R-Wert hat, Brandenburg auch. Also der Osten fällt gerade schneller und macht sich schneller Corona-frei als der Westen.
Mhm. Ja. Kann man sagen.
Oder ob ich irgendwas übersehe, ne? Okay, Sachsen-Anhalt ist ein bisschen höher, aber im Wesentlichen kann man schon sagen, dass das so ein Ostwest-Gefälle hat.
Ja, was aber mal vor ein paar Wochen äh noch mal vor ja zwei Monaten eher noch genau umgekehrt aussah.
Würdest du denn sagen, wie das äh so ist, also wie wie Stabilität ist, ist in diesem Trend drin.
Tja, das ist natürlich ganz, ganz schwer zu sagen, weil wir verschiedene.
Ja Wettläufe haben im Moment grade und wenn man sich außerdem anguckt so.
Die Frage warum
sinken die Zahlen, dann sind es ganz, ganz, ganz viele einzelne Maßnahmen und und Gründe, die wir vielleicht mal durch,
könnten, weil das das lohnt sich, weil sich man sich gar nicht dessen bewusst ist, wie viel Maßnahmen wir denn so aufeinander gestapelt haben und.
Einige davon fallen weg. Einiges davon äh wie eben Impfungen und Saisonalität so.
Nimmt zu und alles andere aber wird ja jetzt zurückgefahren mehr oder weniger.
Und eigentlich ähm müsste, müssten wir äh demnächst äh oder früher oder später nochmal steigende Zahlen.
Sehen, dass es meine Vermutung, wenn jetzt die ganzen Maßnahmen nach und nach wegfallen.
Das war eigentlich zu früh.
Ja, eigentlich, eigentlich wär's gut, wenn das jetzt noch möglichst lange so so bleibt und die Politik hat jetzt so einen, ja,
vorsichtigen Abwehrkampf geführt. Ich glaube, da gab's auch gewisse Lerneffekte. Also es wurde aus meiner Sicht jetzt nicht ganz so schnell gelockert, nicht ganz so voreilig gelockert wie.
Dann im, ja, Februar, wo wir uns eigentlich ziemlich viel versaut haben wieder
und ich habe so auch Aussagen gehört, wenn man sehen, dass äh sollten die Zahlen wieder steigen, dass man diesmal gedenkt halt dann schneller zu reagieren und es nicht nicht wieder ewig abzuwarten, aber.
Wir werden sehen.
Wo hast du das gehört?
Ähm ja es kam, ich ich glaube sogar Spahn hatte das gesagt und so ein paar Landespolitiker kamen da auch mit irgendwie ja wir wollen nicht nochmal die Fehler aus dem letzten Sommer wiederholen.
Ja, aber das werden sie ja dann trotzdem tun. Ich meine, wenn wir jetzt mitten im Sommer steigende Zahlen haben, dann schmeißen sie doch nicht die ganzen Touristen wieder aus den Hotels. Also.
So, ja, jetzt, äh, keine Restaurants mehr, so. Also, das.
Aber statt ja also.
Sagt er dich ja ehrlich, glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, in meinem Clubhaus oder auch in der letzten Sendung schon mal gesagt, ich arbeite gerade mit einem Australier,
zusammen, der eben mir erzählte, ja es ist eben gerade wieder im Lockdown und so und äh alles, alles zu und
was sie dort eben machen ist so wie man das machen sollte, wenn die einen Lockdown gehen, wird halt alles dicht gemacht. Da wird nicht irgendwie so na ja, jetzt sind die gestiegen, dann machen wir mal hier ein bisschen und da ein bisschen in die
in dem Moment, also sie hatten da dreißig Fälle oder so in in einer Stadt plötzlich, von denen sie nicht wussten, äh wo die herkommen so richtig und dann haben sie einfach
alles dicht gemacht jetzt. Und wenn ich mich dann gefragt habe, ja wie lange geht denn das dann? Man sagt, na ja, eine Woche und vielleicht wird dann noch eine Woche verlängert.
Oder so. Und dann wird aber auch äh ja wieder relativ schnell alles wieder auf,
aufgemacht, wobei auch selbst da ähm ist es nicht so, dass das jetzt auch in den sag mal interpandemischen Phasen oder wie auch immer.
Das nennen wir also zwischen den zwischen den Ausbrüchen ist da auch nicht alles, also also die Leute laufen da trotzdem dann mit Masken rum und so.
Also es ist nicht so, dass die jetzt dann gar nichts machen würden, nur weil äh sie dort keine Covid-Fälle haben.
Also von daher und wie gesagt, wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt auf die Frage, oh wie haben wir es denn überhaupt geschafft,
auf null Komma sieben äh zu kommen. Warum sind die Zahlen denn so schnell gefallen und ich glaube, dass ein ganz großer Faktor die,
Ausgangssperren auch waren, die nächtlichen, die äh zu äh deutlich weniger riskanten Kontakten geführt haben, dann.
Ja allgemeine Ausbreitung und Tragen von FFP zwei Masken. So.
Dann natürlich nach wie vor die ganzen Abstandsgebote, die da sind, dann die geschlossenen Geschäfte in Verbindung mit der Abschreckung durch Tests
die man vornehmen musste, dann die ganze Gastronomie, die geschlossen ist oder war Kultureinrichtungen,
Sportstudios, Notbetrieb in Kitas, eingeschränkter Vorlesungsbetrieb an Hochschulen,
Präsenz oder Schließung von Schulen, dann die ganzen Reisebeschränkungen und Beherbung Beherbungsverbote für jetzt Privatreisende und Touristen
außerdem am grundsätzlich weniger Dienstreisen stattgefunden, weniger Leute sind äh ÖPNV gefahren. Ähm
Großveranstaltungen, die seit einem Jahr praktisch verboten sind, die Homeoffice-Quote ist äh
gestiegen. Generell dann auch noch Thema verbesserte Handhygiene, auch wenn das ein bisschen in in äh so,
zurückgetreten äh ist jetzt.
Dann haben glaube ich viele Leute auch äh freiwillig auf unnötige Kontakte jetzt verzichtet, auch vor dem Hintergrund, dass jetzt mehr Leute Impftermine bekommen haben und sich jetzt nicht auf den letzten Metern äh,
das Virus noch ungeschützt einfangen wollen oder noch erst geimpft und sagen sich dann, naja, jetzt warte ich noch mal die paar Wochen passe ich auf, äh bevor ich jetzt rausgehe und
äh um eben auch mir das nicht, nicht einzufangen. Hm.
Ja, äh dann die Impfungen an sich natürlich, die äh auch auf die Inzidenz drücken, wobei.
Das nicht so stark ist, wie viele glauben, meiner Meinung nach, sondern die drücken so vielleicht bisher maximal den R-Wert um null Komma zwei,
ja plus 'ne Saisonalität, also dadurch dass es jetzt wärmer wird
und äh ja, das sind, glaube ich, so eine ist eine ganze Menge Holz und
All jede dieser einzelnen Maßnahmen, selbst wenn die nur zu sagen, null Komma null fünf äh
auf den R-Wert drückt, wenn man sich das dann dann anguckt
und zwanzig mal null Komma null fünf äh macht dann eben auch ähm minus eins beim auf den natürlichen R-Wert des des Virus.
Und äh ja, das denke ich, zusammengenommen hat jetzt zu äh,
Rückgängen geführt, aber von der Liste fällt natürlich jetzt zunehmend mehr weg und das gab's jetzt auch in,
unterschiedlicher Kombination natürlich oder oder Härte in verschiedenen Bundesländern.
Insofern ist jetzt auch nicht alles über einen Kamm äh scheren, aber ich glaube, die die Summe macht's und,
Ja, ich halte einmal die Verbreitung von FFB zwei Masken äh weiterhin für einen für einen ganz ausschlaggebenden.
Tor. Ähm und die,
schon eingangs gesagt habe und die Ausgangssperren, wo ich eben auch am Anfang sehr skeptisch war, haben aber offenbar dazu geführt, dass äh ja, weniger,
Partys äh in den Wohnungen stattgefunden haben, Nachtfall
Offensichtlich war es so, dass in verschiedenen Altersgruppen, nachdem dann die Gastronomie geschlossen waren, die Leute sich halt dann äh zu Hause getroffen haben, in kleineren Gruppen und dort,
und das ist eben auch äh sehr stark reduziert.
Worden, auch Anekdotisch, gab wohl im Clubhaus auch schon erzählt. Ähm es gab wohl eine Umfrage im,
Hamburger, ähm, Presse oder Fernsehen, wo sie Leute gefragt haben, wie sie denn jetzt das mit den Ausgangssperren eigentlich gefunden haben
waren ganze Menge Leute, die meinten, boah super, so toll habe ich lange nicht mehr geschlafen so, die ganzen Partys äh äh,
in den Nachbarwohnungen und der Krach auf der Straße und so und und Verkehr. Also wenn jemand das letzte Mal hinterher so gut.
Auf auf einer Nordseeinsel äh geschlafen irgendwie, wo es keine Autos gibt, die da die da rumfahren. Und insofern äh kann man auch allem irgendwie was Positives,
gewinnen, denke ich.
Ja, nachvollziehbar. Dann haben wir aber auf jeden Fall auch noch den Einfluss der Impfung natürlich. Die.
Zahlen, die werden wir eh gleich nochmal besprechen. Ähm da sind wir noch nicht.
Sind wir noch nicht da, wo wir hinwollen, aber äh wir sind aufm Weg dahin und natürlich hilft jede einzelne Impfung, nur dass sie eben jetzt noch nicht alles verhindert, sondern solange wir
niedrigen Bereichen sind, nimmt's ein Teil raus, aber ohne diese Impfung wären unsere Zahlen auch höher, ganz klar.
Ja. Vielleicht noch ein kleiner Blick zum Schluss der Zahlenbetrachtung äh jetzt auf die äh Testzahlen.
Die Zahl der Tests ist äh jetzt ganz.
Zurückgegangen. Ähm und zwar, ja, hatten wir jetzt zweiundzwanzig Prozent weniger Test, also wenn wir jetzt unter eine Million.
Tests. Neun Komma äh neunhundertsechsunddreißigtausend äh genauer gesagt
aber die Zahl der positiven Tests ist sogar um vierundvierzig Prozent zurückgegangen
so dass ich dann einen Rückgang bei der positiven Quote um siebenundzwanzig Prozent auf nun äh vier Komma eins sechs Prozent
ergeben hat
und ja, vier Komma eins sechs Prozent des ist niedriger als, also es hat mir zuletzt irgendwo in.
Einundvierzig, also Anfang Oktober äh äh glaube ich.
Zweiundvierzig waren wir bei drei Komma fünf acht. Also Ende Oktober, hm.
Ja, also ja, in insofern sind wir jetzt jetzt deutlich äh wenigstens
unter den äh Februar Tiefstwerten äh schon mal schon mal drunter. Und ja, wenn sich die jetzt nochmal,
noch zweimal halbieren würde,
So, dann wenn wir wieder da, wo wir äh dann ja ähm,
genau vor einem Jahr.
Gewesen. Also genau vor einem Jahr so in der, in der KW einundzwanzig,
so zum, zum Vergleich waren wir halt bei einem Prozent, also,
positiven Quote und so unter ein Prozent wäre halt wäre halt super
einfach. Aber dafür müsste ich's, wie gesagt, noch irgendwie zweimal halbieren und ich hoffe, dass das dass das auch auch passiert.
Ja
Schwer einzuschätzen, wie es jetzt kommt, ne. Also.
Unter normalen Umständen ohne diese ganzen Impfungen und ohne die ganze Erfahrung, die jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht Leute auch gesammelt haben,
mal schnell dabei, allen immer vorzuwerfen, sie wären alle so unvorsichtig und sicherlich gilt das auch für einen bestimmten Teil der Bevölkerung, aber ist ja jetzt auch schon so, dass.
Alle haben zwar die Schnauze voll, aber es hat sich auch ein bisschen rumgesprochen, dass man sich's halt selber vergeigen kann.
Und äh das ist eigentlich jetzt das Wichtigste. Jetzt so bisschen noch Füße still halten, was dann sicherlich so ein bisschen zu Gute kommt, ist so ein Effekt, den ich zum Beispiel an mir auch merke. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei dir so ist.
So von null auf hundert jetzt wieder so in seiner alten Verhaltensmuster zurückzukehren.
Jetzt auch nicht so. Also man ist irgendwie zögerlich, man überlegt bei allem, ob das jetzt irgendwie angemessen ist oder ob man sich das nicht doch noch mal sparen sollte und das ist eigentlich genau das richtige Verhalten, um.
Sagen wir mal so einen Wiedergänger ähm so eine so eine Variante, die äh uns droht vielleicht.
Einfach auch frühzeitig zu erkennen, ohne dass gleich die die Zahlen wieder ins absolute Nurvana losschießen.
Also man kann sagen, dass wir jetzt so ja, wenn man jetzt rein die positiv.
Quote äh vergleicht, dann hinken wir so drei bis
vier Wochen hinterher äh gegenüber
letzten Jahr, also hätten wir, hätten wir es nicht so vergeigt mit der mit der dritten,
so hätten wir eigentlich eher drei, vier Wochen voraus sein können. So, also wenn wir dann hätten wir schon vor ja, zwei Monaten oder so
öffnen können oder vor sechs Wochen wahrscheinlich vorsichtig mit Öffnungen beginnen können, aber so ist es jetzt
dass wir äh ja nochmal eben diese dritte Welle eingelegt haben und jetzt äh ja,
ähm schon mal um um die vier Wochen äh vom Frühjahr und Sommer halt uns versaut haben.
Und es ist einiges gestorben, ne? Ich meine, es sind viele Open Air Festivals sind abgesagt worden.
Nicht unbedingt abgesagt werden müssen meiner Auffassung nach, zumindest in einem bestimmten Maße hätten sie äh sicherlich stattfinden können, aber was am Ende gefehlt hat, also tatsächlich wenn jetzt diese Veranstaltung stattfinden.
Im Juni, im Juli äh oder im August.
Dann ist jetzt grade die Wahrscheinlichkeit sogar ganz gut, dass eigentlich die Inzidenzituation das ganze Infektionsgeschehen tatsächlich genau in dem Rahmen ist, in dem man's eigentlich haben will.
Dadurch, dass man sich das nicht sicher sein konnte, weil man einfach so viel Zeit verplempert hat, konnte halt niemand planen.
Niemand hält auch äh den Kopf dafür hin. Ist zum Beispiel so, dass es gibt für Veranstaltungen von der Bundesregierung eine Ausfallsgarantie. Das heißt, Veranstaltungen, wenn die dann.
Abgesagt werden müssen, wegen neuem Infektionsgeschehen, dann gibt's dann so eine Versicherung von der Bundesregierung. Gilt aber erst ab September.
Ja und äh deckt interessanterweise auch.
Diverse Ausnahmen, die jetzt trotzdem noch stattfinden im Rahmen von Modellprojekten, dann überhaupt nicht ab.
Das heißt, gerade die Modellprojekte dürfen dann ähm dürfen dann sozusagen die Verantwortung selber tragen.
Das äh völlig absurd.
Tolles Modellprojekt.
Ganz toll.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, um vielleicht nochmal kurz zu betonen.
Positive Quote unter fünf Prozent, heißt, dass wir jetzt seit langer, langer, langer, langer Zeit, also seit Oktober im Prinzip. Ja, also seit äh jetzt sieben, acht Monaten fast.
Erste Mal wieder unter die Fünf-Prozent-Schwelle äh gekommen sind, die die WHO als so das Maximum ansieht, wo man landen sollte.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt in etwa äh wieder so so die die Kontrolle über das Geschehen dahingehend zurückerlangt, dass wir jetzt unseren Zahlen auch noch trauen können. Also die dunkelste versinkt.
So was, was ich auch noch vergessen hatte zu erwähnen, was natürlich auch noch.
Dazu kommt, ist äh das grundsätzlich je niedriger die Inzidenz umso äh größere Wirkung
entfalten halt das Trekking und Dressing umso mehr können die Gesundheitsämter dann an Zeit und Personal auf einen einzelnen Fall verwenden, ja? Weil
und da gab's haben wir die Diskussion, ja, gibt's da eine magische Grenze irgendwie fünfzig waren da immer im Gespräch, aber das
konnte ich statistisch nirgendwo ablesen, dass es da so einen Punkt gibt, wo dann plötzlich
ja äh die Gesundheitsämter das im Griff haben, sondern ich das ist eher so ein fast
linearer Zusammenhang äh würde ich sagen, wobei klar, irgendwann kommt der Zusammenbruch, aber der liegt halt viel, viel höher als fünfzig. Also das ist dann bei hundert oder zweihundert, wo dann die Gesundheitsämter dann wirklich,
müssen und in dem Bereich darunter, denke ich, ist es einfach so, ähm
je niedriger die Inzidenz äh umso mehr Mühe können sie.
Mit einzelnen Fällen geben und je höher äh die Inzidenz umso schneller müssen sie das abhaken. Ja
Und äh dementsprechend
Ja äh kommt uns das äh jetzt auch auch gerade entgegen und das Lustige ist auch noch auf in der Risikotabelle, habe ich immer so die die Tage bis fünfzig und die Tage bis hundert und da wir jetzt überall
unter fünfzig sind
äh sind die Werte negativ, was man eben so ein bisschen als Sicherheitsabstand interpretieren äh kann, so nach dem Motto, also wenn sich das jetzt genau
umkehren würde, das mit dem R-Wert, also wenn die Zahlen jetzt äh.
So schnell steigen würden, wie sie bisher gesunken sind, dann haben wir jetzt deutschlandweit dreizehn Tage
Sicherheitsabstand zu fünfzig und einen Monat einunddreißig Tage bis bis einhundert ja
und das ist durchaus jetzt keine völlig unlausible Annahme, klar
ähm R-Werte schwanken halt ständig, aber das sind so die die Größenordnungen äh äh gerade. Also selbst wenn's sich jetzt umkehrt,
nicht in einer Woche, wenn wir nicht die hundert dann plötzlich übersteigen und je niedriger die jetzt die Inzidenzen fallen, umso mehr Sicherheits
Abstand haben wir, was aber nicht heißt, dass man den Sicherheitsabstand äh ausnutzen sollte, sondern meiner Meinung nach ähm wäre.
Ja, wie gesagt, so das australische Modell in dem Moment, wo die, wenn die Zahlen jetzt ein, zwei Wochen lang äh steigen, sollte man.
Sofort Lockdown machen oder eigentlich sogar so in dem Moment, wo man einen Fall hat, von dem man nicht weiß, wo er herkommt, äh sollte man eigentlich in den Lockdown gehen.
So, wenn man's identifiziert.
Alles gut, super, dann ist es unter Kontrolle, aber in dem Moment, wo du ein Fall hast und du weißt nicht, wo es herkommt, ist die Infektion außer Kontrolle in einem Landkreis.
Dann laufen ansteckende Leute rum, die du nicht kennst, die nicht in Quarantäne sind und äh ja, die halt dann mal locker
äh eine komplette äh Pandemie wieder lostreten können. Eine komplette Welle lostreten können. Eigentlich einer reicht. Ja, ein Superspray reicht und äh der, der tritt dir eine komplette Pandemie los.
Eine komplette Welle.
Taiwan, ne? Ja, hat mir, glaube ich, vor zwei Wochen.
Kurz berichtet, dass dass da sofort Alarm geschlagen wurde. Ähm ich hatte auch die die optimistische Annahme getroffen, dass die das dann auch schnell wieder in den Griff kriegen. Ist äh erstmal nicht passiert, tatsächlich sind jetzt in Taiwan
erstmalig die äh Inzidenzen da auch hoch geschossen
nicht so hoch, wie sie bei uns sind, aber immerhin so auf äh siebzehn oder sowas, achtzehn
Und jetzt fallen sie wieder eine Weile, aber fallen noch relativ flach so, ah,
das ist im Detail nicht verfolgt. Ähm aber das bestätigt.
Bestätige einfach nur so den Blick. Man muss einfach äh vorsichtig sein. Und wenn du sagst, okay, wir haben jetzt einunddreißig Tage Sicherheitsabstand. Ja, also wenn wir's jetzt eben völlig verkacken, dann sind wir halt auch in einem Monat schon wieder bei hundert und dann bleibt
dann ist er aber auch ein Tag später nicht wieder Unterrunde hat, sondern dann, dann, dann, dann geht die Kurve halt hoch. Es sei denn, man tut halt was dagegen.
Und dann äh sind wir auch schnell wieder bei zweihundert oder vierhundert.
Gucken gleich nochmal auf andere Länder, jetzt äh lass uns doch nochmal ganz kurz äh das Zahlenspiel beenden und ähm kurzen Blick auf die Impfung machen.
Das ist deine Aufgabe Mister Impfstatistik.
Genau. Ja, ähm.
Ich habe mal ähm also ich hole mir ja immer die Daten vom Impf-Dashboard, da gibt's die so zum Download
das war jetzt relativ anexciting und vor allem hat man auch gesehen wieder mal
dass äh auch diese äh wir haben das genannt hier unser Sampling Artefakt, also unser christlicher Sabling Artefakt.
Auch hier äh zuschlägt
Ähm ja, man kann im Prinzip sehr einfach auf zwei Zahlen zusammen äh bringen, ne, wo wir gerade stehen. Fünfundvierzig und zwanzig. Nämlich, das sind jetzt so die Prozentzahlen
die wir an Erstimpfung und ähm Zweitimpfung erreicht haben. Oder genau genommen, man muss ja sagen,
Mindestimpfung und ähm vollständige Impfung in gewisser Hinsicht. Mir ist nämlich selber äh gerade erst kurz vor der Sendung noch ein Detail aufgefallen, was ich eigentlich noch reinrechnen wollte, bis ich festgestellt habe
dass es schon drin ist, nämlich in dieser Zahl der Erstimpfung, die also jetzt bei knapp fünfundvierzig Prozent steht.
Da steckt drin, die ersten Impfungen von bayerntech, moderner und asrasinika, aber auch die Impfung von Johnson und Johnson.
Was sinnvoll ist, weil die Leute, die Johnson und Johnston kriegen, die äh
Na ja, haben ja sozusagen auch eine eine Initialenschutz und die werden ja dann nicht nochmal mit irgendwas erst geimpft, was äh zweitgeimpft werden muss, ne.
Und ähm genauso stecken sie aber auch in dieser Zahl der vollständigen Impfungen, weil.
Ist ja dann auch vollständig, ne. Und ähm von daher äh stimmen die Zahlen auch.
Ich habe das mehrfach ähm so nachvollzogen und halte das für ganz glaubwürdig, soweit eben die Zahlen an sich, die gemeldet werden, stimmen.
Wenn man so über die Tage das so verfolgt, ist immer ganz interessant zu sehen, es gibt Tage, da gibt es sehr viele Nachmeldungen, also grad jetzt so nach Pfingsten trudelte danach schnell mal was ein und dann hat's da so in zwei Tagen mal so.
Zwanzigtausend Nachmeldungen, gibt aber auch andere Tage, wo es irgendwie nur so zehn, zwanzig, dreißigtausend sind,
aber abgesehen von diesen Tagesveröffentlichungen und diesen Erhaltschen nach irgendwelchen Rekorden ähm bedeutet, dass das eigentlich so jeden Tag auch immer wieder,
relativ signifikant äh nachgemeldet wird und sozusagen die Zahlen auch nachträglich alle steigen.
Derzeit sind wir so bei siebenhunderttausend Impfungen pro Tag im Schnitt, also im Wochenschnitt.
Und ähm ungefähr so bei vierhundertzwanzigtausend für.
Die äh Zweitimpfung und knapp unter dreihunderttausend für die Erstimpfung und das wird jetzt auch noch so eine Weile so gehen. Wir haben so ein Verhältnis von sechzig vierzig bei den Zweitimpfungen zu Erstimpfungen,
und da jetzt nochmal so ein kleines, so eine kleine Welle ansteht, weil wir ja quasi die Erstimpfung vor sechs Wochen.
Durchführen müssen, wenn beginnt also jetzt so grad so ein bisschen so dieses schwierige Tal, was durch durchmarschiert werden muss, also zumindest die nächste Woche wird nochmal so voll im im Trend der Zweitimpfung sein.
Und danach wird's halt besser. Erstens, weil der Bedarf nach Zweidimpfungen absinkt und weil dann eben auch die Lieferzahlen ansteigen sollen, also das.
Werden wir sehen, ob das dann so kommt, aber bisher waren ja eigentlich die von die Aussagen von Bier und Tisch immer relativ klar und wenn sie's dann doch mal nicht schaffen können, haben sie es auch frühzeitig kommuniziert, wie eben jetzt vor
zwei Wochen, als sie gesagt haben, dass sie eben mal so locker eine halbe Million weniger liefern pro Woche für zwei Wochen. Das aber dann eben gegen Ende Juni nachholen.
Ja, wobei sagtest du, aber wenn ich mir deine Grafik an.
Äh Erreichten, die hm, okay, ja gut,
vierzehnten, fünfzehnten rum, wird quasi Peak-Zweitimpfungsbedarf erstmal erreicht, oder? Das also und das geht noch bis
fast bis Ende Juni äh äh so geht's, geht's dann.
Erst wirklich signifikant äh runter, so dass wir wahrscheinlich bei dem bis dahin so grob,
bei der Situation bleiben werden.
Na ja, ist schon ein bisschen anders, weil wir halt äh jetzt von so knapp dreihundert, also wir hatten jetzt äh, ich gucke mal, die Zeit noch mal genauer an, damit ich jetzt hier keinen Unsinn erzähle,
Also wir haben jetzt äh wir sind ja jetzt in der KW na ja KW sind wir jetzt gerade, nicht durcheinander kommen, Tim, bleibt dabei, wir sind jetzt in K wie,
zweiundzwanzig, ne? Und für KW zweiundzwanzig, also in dieser Woche werden,
deutlich mehr Dosen geliefert.
Während wir also in der letzten Woche grade mal so in der Summe auf fünf Millionen kamen, werden es voraussichtlich Ende dieser Woche dann über sechs knapp sechseinhalb Millionen gewesen sein.
Das ist äh vor allem aber nicht ausschließlich auf eine Steigerung bei äh Biotech zurückzuführen.
Aber auch diese Johnson und Johnson äh Waxine kommen jetzt ähm vermehrt an und werden auch vermehrt geimpft, also da sind auch die Impfzahlen extrem angestiegen und das wird schon dazu beitragen, ne. Also wir werden,
Ende dieser Woche mal äh ja so eins Komma acht Millionen mehr,
Impfdosen haben und das wird dann eben dazu beitragen, dieses Zweitimpfungspolster schnell abzutragen und in dem Moment, wo das dann.
Absinkt, geht das dann eben so weiter. Die Prognosen sind dann für die Folgewochen ein bisschen zurückhaltender, also es geht dann ähm so auf äh fünf Komma fünf und fünf Millionen zurück.
Das ist halt schade, das sind sozusagen diese Lieferungen in in dreiundzwanzig und vierundzwanzig, die eigentlich höher sein sollten, aber das wird dann alles nachgeliefert und dann halt
in für KW fünfundzwanzig und sechsundzwanzig gehen wir dann irgendwie auf sieben Millionen hoch.
Das heißt, dann werden wir wirklich eine Beschleunigung sehen. Also mal so eine richtige Beschleunigung bei den Erstimpfungen, weil eben Zweitimpfungs äh Welle durch ist und dann.
Sehr viel mehr Impfstoff zur Verfügung steht und ich glaube, da werden wir uns dann alle sehr äh über die Zahlen freuen.
Sodass dann auch äh pünktlich zum Ende der Urlaubssaison dann auch alle geimpft sind.
Na ja, zumindest pünktlich zum Anfang der Urlaubssaison schon mal die allermeisten auch wirklich eine Erstimpfung erhalten haben, ne. Ich meine, wenn wir jetzt auf fünfundvierzig Prozent schauen, dann bedeutet das ja.
Ähm der Leute, die sich derzeit überhaupt impfen lassen dürfen. Und das heißt ja, sechzehn plus.
Und wenn man das eben auf diesen Bevölkerungsanteil äh hochrechnet, dann sind wir halt schon so bei sechsundfünfzig Prozent oder so.
Ja, das ist auch nochmal ein interessanter Punkt, ja. Dass ja immer die sagen, die Impfquoten, die Offiziellen immer auf die Gesamtbevölkerung.
Richtig. Aber nicht auf alle, die sich impfen lassen können, ne? So, das heißt, ähm.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen schwer zu schlussfolgern, wie viele Leute würden sich jetzt impfen lassen? Wir hatten ja so diese Aussage von äh in der letzten Sendung, glaube ich, vom RKI mit ja fünfundsiebzig Prozent wollen sich auf jeden Fall impfen lassen. Fünfundsiebzig Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Ja gut, also und und wie ist es jetzt mit sechzehn plus? Also ist es da irgendwie auch fünfundsiebzig Prozent oder ist es irgendwie da mehr und es sind dann Kinder überhaupt gefragt worden, also so ein bisschen so eine ähm leere Aussage, wie das immer so ist, man muss immer,
ganz genau hinschauen.
Ja, also ich bin da verhalten äh optimistisch, dass das jetzt ganz gut weitergehen soll und vor allem, was auch äh vielen nicht so richtig auffällt, ist, dass wir halt auch,
im Vergleich mit anderen Ländern äh in zunehmendem Maße aufholen.
Ja ähm und dass wir auch teilweise andere, dass sich auch zeigt, dass dass wir so andere Strategien haben. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal Deutschland mit ähm UK vergleichen.
Beim äh Impfen, ja, dann haben wir halt äh kommen wir sozusagen dem.
Erstimpfpotential von UK äh zunehmend nahe. Also wir haben deutlich höhere Anstiegsraten derzeit, als es in UK ist.
Also wir mit unseren fünfundvierzig Prozent und UK ist so kurz unter sechzig.
Mhm. Auf Gesamtbevölkerung bezogen.
Alles auf die Gesamtbevölkerung bezogen, genau.
Und ähm nur, dass sie halt eben bei der bei der Zweitimpfung äh auch nochmal deutlich weiter vorne liegen mit irgendwie ungefähr dem Doppelten von dem, was wir haben.
Aber auch da holen wir jetzt schnell auf. Also es denke mal, es es wird sich einiges egalisieren jetzt im nächsten Monat und dann wird man eben schauen, welche Auswirkungen das äh letzten Endes hat.
So viel, glaube ich, erstmal zum ähm allgemeinen Impfthema.
Äh äh vielleicht noch einen Nachtrag. Ähm.
Und zwar, wo ich auch auf Twitter äh ordentlich drüber gegrübelt habe, ist so dieses äh Asraziniker. Wenn man sich die Kurven anschaut für die Zweitimpfung, dann sieht man, dass eigentlich der Bedarf für äh Asra Senicker Zweitimpfung.
Also es müssten jetzt eigentlich mal locker doppelt so viele Asra Zweitimpfungen durchgeführt werden, als tatsächlich stattfinden.
Also es ist eine extrem äh hohe Zahl und ist ein bisschen unklar, wo die so äh hingegangen sind.
Es macht schon so den Eindruck, als ob's dann doch schon eine verstärkte Abwanderung in Richtung Biotech gibt. Also das ist wirklich relativ viele Leute, die eigentlich jetzt für eine Zweitimpfung mit Asra äh vorgesehen waren.
Dass die ähm auf moderner oder auf Biotich umsteigen.
Ja? Und das macht ja auch Sinn, hatten wir ja hier auch schon letzte Mal diese spanische Studie äh besprochen, gucken auch gleich nochmal auf die auf die von der Charité, die sich das ja auch nochmal angeschaut haben.
Und äh ich habe mich vor allem gefragt, ob das nicht vielleicht sogar eine gute Idee wäre. Ähm generell da.
Umzusteigen.
Absolut.
Und zwar äh weiß ich, welchen ersten Gedanken du jetzt hattest.
Mach du erstmal.
Naja, ich dachte mir so.
Wenn die Kombination aus Asra Senica, also aus, ich sage mal aus Vektor Impfstoff plus äh RNA Impfstoff so geil ist. Ja, also alle Studien sagen.
Kann man machen bis hin zu,
steigert einfach nochmal die ganze Antikörperreaktion, die ganze äh Immunreaktion des Körpers signifikant, ohne dass es jetzt nennenswert viel mehr Probleme macht. Und wenn das so eine tolle Kombination ist.
Warum bietet man dann nicht explizit sogar diese Kombination an und nimmt einfach generell nur noch als Erstimpfstoff und haut einfach äh RNA hinter rein?
So, ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass die ständige Impfkommission äh das irgendwann äh sogar empfehlen wird, wird man sehen. Die sind ja immer ein bisschen
vorsichtiger äh so und äh insofern äh ja, absolut Plus
worauf wir auch im äh letzten Clubhaus nochmal aufmerksam gemacht
wurden, dass Leute, die jetzt eine Erstimpfung mit Astrasinika bekommen haben, eigentlich ganz gute Karten haben
ähm eine äh Zweitimpfung äh mit äh Bieren zu äh oder mit einem RNA Impfstoff
bekommen, weil äh ja und zwar aus zwei Gründen.
Zum einen äh ist es so, also zumindest für alle unter Sechzigjährigen, die aus irgendeinem Grund äh eine Erstimpfung mit Astra Senica.
Erhalten haben, ist ja im Moment äh die Empfehlung tatsächlich auch ähm sagen die nicht.
Äh Astra Senica zwei zu impfen. Das heißt, man kann sich gegenüber dem Arzt sogar äh oder wo auch immer darauf berufen, dass das eigentlich so die Empfehlung äh äh ist, der der Impfkommission
halt. Ähm,
und der zweite Punkt äh auch, äh was man als Argument beim Arzt äh in die Wege führen äh kann, ist, dass in den meisten Bundesländern zumindest, so wie ich das mitbekommen habe, ist die gängige Praxis ist.
Ärzte für Zweitimpfungen äh bestellen können
was sie wollen an Impfstoffen, während für die Erstimpfung, so müssen sie mehr oder weniger noch nehmen, was sie, was sie kriegen, aber für die Zweitimpfung kriegen sie in der Regel genau das, was sie,
sie bestellen und ich sage mal, diese beiden Sachen zusammen sollten es eigentlich ermöglichen, so diese beiden Argumente, das,
unabhängig
jetzt von der Empfehlung der Impfkommission dann, glaube ich, ganz gute Karten und Argumente äh hat dann gegenüber dem Arzt zu sagen, ich hätte das gerne, wenn man das äh bevorzugt.
Ich freue mich auch gerade, ob die Ärzte eigentlich irgendwas dagegen haben können. Ich meine
klar äh Biotech ist groß nachgefragt und die haben sicherlich so ein bisschen Sorgen, was Rasinika loszuwerden, aber der Vorteil ist natürlich bei dieser expliziten Kombi, dass man eben auch diesen Impfabstand äh wieder geringer wählen kann.
Ja, also es muss nicht unbedingt auf diese zwölf Wochen hinauslaufen. Wir hatten ja jetzt gerade die Ansage vom Gesundheitsministeriums
dass äh Asra jetzt auch nach vier Wochen die Zweitimpfung erfolgen äh kann
alle die Hände heben und sagen, äh Moment, das hat aber irgendwie einen medizinischen Sinn, dass wir da zwölf Wochen machen, wegen der potenziellen Immunität, die der Körper eben, zumindest kurzfristig, gegen diesen Vektorvirus als Seuchen entwickelt.
Dieses Problem fällt bei der Kombiimpfung komplett weg und man kann halt irgendwie so einen mittelground finden und sagen, okay, dann machen wir halt,
acht Wochen oder sechs Wochen, weil die Wirkung der Erstimpfung ist dann auf jeden Fall da und der RNA Impfstoff kann.
Wird sozusagen keine ja stört sich nicht an einer Immunität gegen das Vektorvirus, weil da ist kein Vektorvirus drin. So und dann ist ja eigentlich auch allen geholfen.
Längeren Abstand machen, man kann einen kürzeren Abstand machen und man kombiniert's einfach und es ist vor allem und das war so ein bisschen mein Hintergedanke
Viele Leute sind so zögerlich bei Asra Senica, weil das irgendwie so einen schlechten Ruf hat, aber wenn man halt das Ganze eben verbinden kann mit na ja, äh
dieses äh diese Erstimpfung hat den Vorteil,
dass wenn du dann die Zweitimpfung und was anderem bekommst, dass dein Schutz sehr viel höher ist und potenziell auch noch länger hält. Und das ist ja durchaus ein Argument, wo Leute sagen können, so ja, na klar, wenn das so ist, erstens kriege ich jetzt schon meine Erstimpfung, die ich sonst vielleicht gar nicht bekommen würde und zweitens habe ich am Ende.
Auch noch ähm einen besseren Schutz.
Ja, plus, äh, dass man wahrscheinlich auch einen äh besseren Schutz vor manchen Varianten hat. Mein Astrasinika schützt zwar
auch bei allen Varianten, vor schweren Verlauf und Tod,
so, aber ähm vor
Erkrankung zum Beispiel äh ist bei der Südafrika-Variante, ist es so
dass dort ja Studie war, dass das, was so Erkrankungen angeht
Ja, man in der Statistik, also Infektion, nicht Erkrankung, sorry. Das äh eben äh Astra Senicam bei der Südafrika-Variante praktisch nicht
äh äh schützt äh vor Infektionen äh zumindest.
Und ähm ja äh und wir haben diese Variante ist zwar bei uns jetzt nicht
kaufen oder kaum verbreitet, bisschen mehr Sorgen macht halt grade die indische Variante. So, wir müssen jetzt, es gab ja jetzt auch diese Umbenennung.
Ja, ja, da kommen wir gleich noch drauf, ja.
Ähm wenn ich mich auch erstmal dran gewöhne, habe ich noch nicht wirklich verinnerlicht.
Das ja bringt uns, glaube ich, jetzt der nur mehr durcheinander. Das stellen wir nachher vor, dann überlegen wir mal, ob wir drauf umsteigen.
Genau, also ähm ja, mit anderen äh äh Worten äh sagen die, die die Kombiimpfung äh dürfte auch insgesamt äh wahrscheinlich einen einen breiteren Variantenschutz äh bieten äh sage ich mal. Nach
nach Studienlage so ist, so wie es aussieht und äh ja, insofern,
Wäre das halt ganz cool, äh wenn das allgemeine Praxis wäre, aber wie gesagt äh man kann dadurch Eigeninitiative, glaube ich, hat man ganz gute Karten äh
sagen wir erstens 'ne Erstimpfung mit Astra zu bekommen, weil äh das nicht so attraktiv zu sein scheint und wenn man die dann hat man hab ich ganz gute Karten äh
auch eben äh bei der bei der zweiten Dosis dann äh den Impfstoff seiner Wahl äh zu bekommen.
Ja, schauen wir nochmal auf die äh Diskussion mit den äh mit der Info von Kindern, wie heißt es ja schon erwähnt, wir äh hatten da letzte Mal so eine Diskussion und ähm haben sich ein paar neue Aspekte äh ergeben, ne?
Ja, also ich hatte mich ja äh insbesondere etwas darüber ereifert äh über
ähm einen einen Interview, was äh der Vorsitzende, der der ständigen Impfkommission Professor Mertens gegenüber Phönix gegeben hat, wo er sich da zu so einem paar lapidaren
äh ich fand und ja sportlichen Aussagen hatte hinreißen lassen, wie sagen, okay, alle Kinder
sterben praktisch an,
äh äh mit äh Corona und nicht äh an äh Corona und äh außerdem, dass äh halt auch ansonsten äh ja, die, die
Auswirkungen der Krankheit, also.
Und äh Lonkovic äh und so, äh dass das ähm praktisch nicht existent äh wäre, ja. So,
und beides fand ich,
als als äh so pauschale Aussage erstmal nicht nicht haltbar. So, weil normalerweise, also,
An sich äußern äh äh sich ja gerade, ich sage mal die Fach
also von Drosten ist man das ja gewohnt, immer äh sehr, sehr vorsichtig und mit sehr, sehr vielen Jahr wahrscheinlich und vielleicht und das deutet darauf hin und so und das hatte er halt in dem Interview,
dort nicht getan, ja. Und ich hatte mich dann zum einen auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr ans Rechnen gemacht, dass ich jetzt auf Twitter.
Sagen mal erste Berechnungen äh angestellt für die Altersgruppen, wer.
Stirbt den an und mit Corona. Das kann man eigentlich ganz gut,
machen, äh also die wenn man die die die Sterblichkeit
hat in den entsprechenden Altersgruppen und dann kann man gucken äh wie hoch lag denn die Sterblichkeit jetzt
in den Altersgruppen, bei denen dienen positiven Coronatest hatten, zu sagen. Und ähm das ist.
Sehr, sehr eindeutig in den höheren Altersgruppen, also da haben wir also deutschlandweit kann man sagen, das hat mir auch schon vor Monaten hatte ich mal
für die Gesamtbevölkerung berechnet. Größenordnungsmäßig kann man sagen, äh drei Prozent äh der
Bevölkerung sterben im Schnitt mit Corona, also wären halt.
Innerhalb von äh dreißig Tagen nach einem positiven Coronatest,
ohnehin verstorben, aber siebenundneunzig Prozent kann man sagen, ja also,
Ähm sterben dann wirklich an äh Corona. So.
Und bei den Kindern äh sieht es aber da einen einen bisschen anders aus, so äh je nach Altersgruppen und da ist so ein bisschen das Problem, dass bei den Kindern.
Auch genauere Daten fehlen. Insofern äh gibt's da ein paar Schwierigkeiten, zumindest in der Altersgruppe null bis vier, weil
ist eine sehr, sehr hohe Säuglingssterblichkeit gibt
ist halt schon so, dass ja von den Kindern, die geboren werden, ein gewisser Anteil äh einfach nicht überlebt,
so und zwar einen wesentlich höheren Anteil, aber wenn äh erhalten ein Kind erstmal ja die ersten mal Lebensmonate, das erste Lebensjahr übersteht, dann äh.
Ja, dann singt eben die die natürliche Sterblichkeit um den Faktor zehn. Ja, also im ersten Lebensjahr, im ersten Lebensmonaten, sterben halt im Schnitt zehnmal so viele Kinder wie,
halt dann über über ein Jahr. Das macht natürlich gut da auf der anderen Seite sind die Daten,
ist das genaue Alter, der der verstorbenen zumindest nicht öffentlich bekannt, jetzt der verstorbenen Kinder, dass das halt ein bisschen schwierig wird von von außen. Das Ganze hm für, sage mal, die.
Die Nulljährigen äh dann äh,
auch äh sauber zu zu rechnen, ob's da eine Übersterblichkeit gibt und da werden wir die null bis vier haben, ähm so ähm ja,
ähm ist das ist das Ergebnis so ein bisschen problematisch. Ähm.
Genauer gesagt ist das Ergebnis halt, dass wenn man jetzt einfach null bis vier betrachtet, kriegt man nur einen einen Übersterblichkeits äh Faktor von eins Komma vier
ungefähr raus, was bedeutet das, ja, vierzig Prozent mit und sechzig Prozent an äh Corona sterben
aber äh ja, das sind halt alles auch noch,
eben sehr, sehr kleine Zahlen. Also wir reden hier von acht Todesfällen
in der in der Gruppe null bis vier und der Erwartungswert wäre halt fünf Komma sieben so und das kann natürlich durch durch Zufall
Also wenn du.
Irgendwie eine Erwartungswert von eins hast und da kommen jetzt zwei oder drei raus, dann kann das halt auch reiner Zufall äh sein. Das ist sagen,
Das erste Problem, das zweite,
Problem ist, hm dass äh ja die Dunkelziffern natürlich auch möglicherweise eine eine Rolle spielen und das bei äh gerade Kindern, die Dunkelziffer.
Potenziell höher ist oder sehr wahrscheinlich sogar höher ist. Das heißt, wenn man das jetzt nicht auf Basis der positiven Tests rechnen würde, sondern auf die Zahl der tatsächlichen Infektionen, die wir aber nicht wirklich
kennen, weil es äh einfach an breit angelegten Studien mangelt äh äh dazu, weil dazu müsste man dann.
Eben im großen Stil auch.
Antikörpertests machen und das gibt's nur vereinzelt so in einzelnen Regionen und die Region wiederum können da sehr, sehr große Unterschiede haben.
Ja aus aus verschiedensten Gründen, also mit anderen Worten, die Zahlen sind halt grade bei den, bei den Kindern eben sehr, sehr problematisch. Weiterer äh Grund, warum sagen diese Übersterblichkeits.
Rechnung möglicherweise ähm einen einen anderen Effekt haben kann, ist, dass,
Gruppe der Kinder, die getestet wurde nicht
sagen der Gesamtpopulation der Kinder entspricht, sondern das sind halt Kinder, die möglicherweise ohnehin krank waren und vielleicht
etwas äh ja
gesundheitlich äh nicht ganz so belastbar sind und dass man aus diesem Grund dort auch gegenüber der der Gesamtbevölkerung in dem Alter dann eine Übersterblichkeit
sieht.
Es gab ja dieses Interview mit dem äh Mellard von der von der äh der Chef der Sticko, äh also der ständigen Impfkommission.
Mertens. Mertens heißt der.
Letzten Coronavirus, Update, Podcast mit Sandra äh Zieseck und ich fand das ganz interessant, weil er halt
explizit auch nochmal genauer zu diesem Thema befragt wurde und ein bisschen mehr Raum und Zeit hatte, als in dem von dir äh kritisierten Phoenix-Interview, das auch nochmal alles zu erläutern. Und genau zu dem Punkt, den du gerade erwähnt hast, äh sagte er, wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere,
ähm bei den Todesfällen, die da gesehen wurden, das irgendwo war, dass die alle ohnehin schon palliativ behandelt wurden. Also das waren.
Todkranke Kinder, die aus anderen Gründen äh krank waren. Und auch die Zahl von Hospitalisierung.
Muss man relativieren, weil's nicht selten auftritt, dass eben einfach Kinder aus ganz anderen Gründen,
ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert werden, sagen wir mal, Blinddarmoperation steht an, ja? Und dann immer, wenn du ins Krankenhaus kommst, wirst du ohnehin getestet. Und dann zeigt sich halt einfach, dass die dann eben in dem Fall.
Angesteckt waren, obwohl sie es vielleicht äh noch gar nicht wussten. Und generell sind überhaupt so die.
Diejenigen, die im Krankenhaus eingeliefert werden, die allerwenigsten davon ähm brauchen überhaupt irgendeine Intensivmedizinische Behandlung.
Oft ist es halt einfach so, dass nach einer.
Äh erkannten, symptomatischen Infektionen, die Kinder eigentlich eher als Vorsichtsmaßnahme ins Krankenhaus gebracht werden, weil man einfach aus irgendwelchen Gründen Dinge ausschließen möchte äh oder äh ne.
Grundsätzlich bei Kindern da ein bisschen vorsichtiger ist.
Also mein ein interessanter Punkt war, ich hatte mich halt erstmal als ich die also ich hatte dann
erstmal noch einen einen Zahlenfehler äh äh drin, äh rechten Fehler drin in meiner ersten
Variante von der Sterblichkeitsberechnung bei Kindern, wo ich auf etwas höhere Werte gekommen bin, weil wie ich die
Sterblichkeitszahlen, die ich genommen hatte, schon auf Bevölkerung normiert waren, das war mir da noch nicht aufgefallen. Ich ein dummer Fehler, aber,
selbst nachdem das das korrigiert ist blieb halt schon ein bisschen über Sterblichkeit äh übrig, aber wenn man.
Sagen jetzt Dunkelziffer und und so mit mit einbezieht, wie gesagt, ist äh verschwindet äh der Effekt zumindest in der
in der Altersgruppe ähm fünf bis vierzehn, aber dann hat man wiederum bei der Altersgruppe null bis vier, das Problem, wenn man annimmt, dass es diesen Effekt gibt
dass man dann auf eine Untersterblichkeit,
Gruppe käme bei Coronainfizierten, was nicht sein kann, ja? Also mit anderen Worten, die ganze Zahlen äh Lage ist halt,
uneindeutig und äh man kann äh mit den Zahlen weder das eine noch das andere jetzt wirklich klar legen,
Ich sehe nach wie vor vor allem mit Zahlen jetzt, wenn man noch aus dem Ausland dazunimmt, äh von den wirklich tausenden an Kindern, die jetzt in Brasilien zum Beispiel verstorben äh sind und auch aus anderen Ländern.
Würde ich sagen, ist es schon so und das das hat dann der Mertens.
Glaube ich auch dann entsprechend vorsichtiger ausgedrückt in dem in dem in dem längeren Podcast äh dass er dann nicht pauschal gesagt hat, ja nee, spielt gar keine Rolle. Äh,
oder die Kinder sterben gar nicht an äh äh Corona, sondern nur ähm ja, dass es dass es halt halt eher unklar.
Ist und ich hatte mich dann auch glaube ich,
der Bewertung dessen, also der der Zahlen eigentlich auch ein bisschen zurückgehalten, weil.
Ähm ganz unabhängig jetzt von der von der übersterblichkeit, äh wie hoch die jetzt tatsächlich,
ist, ist die gar nicht das eigentliche Problem. Das ist dann fast eine akademische äh äh Debatte aus meiner Sicht, weil die Zahlen sind ebenso niedrig, das im Vergleich zu anderen Lebens,
Risiken und Erkrankungen, das eher zurück
ja so, dass man sich und das hat mir glaube ich auch.
Sagt also für Eltern gibt's da jetzt keinen Grund äh große Angst zu haben, dass dass,
eigene Kleinkind jetzt an Corona stirbt, so das ist ja so so minimal,
da kann man glaub ich eher entspannt sein bisschen,
anders noch sehe ich das jetzt mit Thema und wo eben auch eine ja gerade Kontroverse Debatte stattfindet.
Bei wie viel Kindern äh das jetzt eigentlich stattfindet. Da hatte sich Mertens in dem in dem.
Phönix äh Interview auch ähm geäußert dahingehend, dass eigentlich also dieses gibt's eigentlich gar nicht und äh also bin ich das entnommen, also ist dass das praktisch irgendwie ja äh mehr oder weniger Hysterie äh
ist und andere Argument waren, na ja, die Studie aus England, die ich zum Beispiel zitiert hatte, die halt
besagte, dass nach drei Monaten ungefähr fünf Prozent, also zwischen fünf und zehn Prozent der Kinder noch Symptome hatten. Äh.
Wurde dann erwidert, na ja, aber äh das müssen nicht unbedingt Symptome sein, äh die jetzt auf die,
Corona-Erkrankung zurückzuführen sind und außerdem so ein bisschen hüsteln oder äh so ein bisschen Schlappheit, das kann halt auch von von ganz anderen,
Ding kommen, ja? Also insofern sei das gar nicht gar nicht aussagekräftig diese Studie.
Sicherlich stimmt ist äh ja, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht die die fünf bis zehn Prozent, äh die dann noch Symptome haben, da muss man gewiss einiges ähm von abziehen, aber auf der
anderen Seite ist ist mein Eindruck ähm nicht der, dass das jetzt komplette Fantasie ist. Vor allen Dingen
finde ich's halt dann ein bisschen schwierig auch gegenüber den Betroffenen äh zu behaupten, äh so äh nee, äh
Okay, ihr habt zwar jetzt irgendwie Atemnot und äh seid müde und könnt nicht gut schmecken und nicht gut riechen
äh und so, aber das hat jetzt mit äh eurer Corona-Infektion nichts zu tun, ja. Das
das finde ich ein bisschen schwierig sich auf den Standpunkt zu stellen, aber ich glaube auch, dass Herr Mertens das, glaube ich, auch jetzt im im neuen Podcast,
in dem Podcast auch nicht so aus mehr mehr so ausgedrückt hat.
Ja, ich kann mich da jetzt ehrlich gesagt grade an die Details nicht äh erinnern, mir äh erschienen, aber die ganze Darlegung der Sachlage relativ nachvollziehbar.
Äh ohne jetzt vielleicht jetzt äh uns, dass wir uns zu sehr jetzt in den Details mit wie viel Zahlen jetzt auf was wir äh hinweisen, ähm uns zu verlieren
kann man vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen auf die auf die generelle Aussage, was soll denn jetzt eigentlich was sollte denn jetzt eigentlich geschehen, vorspulen? Und da vertritt er ja im Prinzip eine klare Meinung, nämlich die,
Also die.
Macht derzeit vor allem deshalb keine grundsätzliche Aussage für die Impfung, weil's A.
Erstmal gar nicht erforderlich ist, dadurch dass jetzt die Impfung für zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährige erlaubt.
Ja? Kann das auch jede Familie entsprechend entscheiden. Also wenn jetzt ähm.
Jemand möchte, dass Kinder in dem Alter geimpft werden? Dann kann man das jetzt machen. Gehen wir zum Kinderarzt.
Eine Liste ein und dann kann eine Impfung erfolgen. Das verhindert das nicht. Andererseits sagt aber die Stiko-Art nicht.
Das muss jetzt unbedingt erforderlich äh stattfinden.
Sie sagen es nur und da aber auch wiederum explizit für Kinder mit Vorerkrankungen. Also wo ist es, sich jetzt sozusagen anbietet, ist, wenn die Kinder in irgendeiner Form.
Irgendwas haben, kann ja jetzt nichts aufzählen, aber das wisst ihr ja im Zweifelsfall alles selber, weil dadurch natürlich klar, ne, also Diabetes ist, glaube ich, so ein ganz äh klassischer Fall, ne, also die Kinder Diabetes haben, dann ganz klar impfen. Denn,
und da, das kann ja auch vollkommen nachvollziehen.
Es ist ja uns klar, dass Kinder in dem Alter deutlich geringeres Risiko haben, jetzt wirklich Schaden zu nehmen, als zum Beispiel.
Vierzig, Fünfzigjährige, wo es noch so einige von gibt, die jetzt eben durchaus auch noch Impfbedarf haben. Und es gibt halt kein separates Kontingent an Impfstoffen, was nur für Kinder ist.
Gibt's, glaube ich, noch so ein bisschen Konfusion, ob da jetzt irgendwie aktiv wirklich was vor vorgehalten wird. Ich glaube es ist irgendwie nicht so. Auf jeden Fall würden natürlich die Impfstoffe, die jetzt hier bei den Kindern verimpft werden,
zwangsläufig aus dem Kontingent weggehen, was sonst anderen Leuten zukommen würde. Und dann ist halt die Frage, okay, wer.
Wie ist jetzt der Allgemeinheit am besten Schutz getan? Ne und ähm sicherlich wäre es unklug zu sagen
alle mal herhören, wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie drei Millionen zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährige in Deutschland, ich glaube das sind etwa so die Zahl, ich hab das von dir so die Bevölkerungszahlen bekommen, also zwei Komma neun bis drei Millionen, so in der Größenordnung durfte sich das in etwa bewegen
Würden wir die halt alle,
ähm erst impfen und Zweitimpfen, dann ist das quasi so der Impfstoffbedarf, den wir in zwei Wochen so für eine Woche haben.
Klingt wenig, aber ne, sechs Millionen im äh Impfstoffdosen heißt eben, dass es sich dann eben für andere Leute entsprechend verzögert.
Nee, absolut, also wenn man auf die auf die Zahlen äh guckt, also meine Übersterblichkeits äh Berechnung, die ich durchgeführt habe, da ergibt sich auch ganz klar raus, du willst erst die Erwachsenen,
impfen, ähm weil dort die Impfung äh äh wesentlich mehr
Sinn äh macht jetzt im Sinne von von Übersterblichkeit, also viel mehr schwere Verläufe, Hospitalisierung und Todesfälle äh vermeidet sozusagen. Da ist ähm da.
Macht es einfach Sinn, wenn die, wenn die Kinder ein bisschen zurückstehen äh an an der äh Stelle und da bin ich da bin ich mir dann an der Stelle wieder äh komplett,
eigentlich auch mit äh Mertens und der äh der STIKO. Das ist halt halt ganz klar. Ähm interessante Anomalie habe ich aber noch noch festgestellt. Ähm.
Und zwar bei fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig komme ich äh auf ähm eine.
Höhere.
Übersterblichkeit als bei der Gruppe fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig. Kann jetzt auch an, wie gesagt, Verzerrungseffekten äh liegen, aber äh äh zumindest da ergibt,
sich äh schon des, wenn man jetzt nicht auf die absolute Sterblichkeit guckt, sondern nur sagen, auf verlorene Lebensjahre zum Beispiel, würde es jetzt keinen Sinn machen, aus meiner Sicht,
die Altersgruppe fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig
vor fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig zu priorisieren, sondern da äh wir sagen, alles so ab fünfzehn oder oder zwanzig oder so äh
dürfte aus verschiedensten Gründen die gleiche Priorität äh haben, aber eben bei bei unter fünfzehn äh definitiv äh ist das ist das völlig richtig äh erstmal,
Älteren äh zu impfen, bevor man äh dann anfängt zu sagen, gesunde oder nicht vorerkrankte äh Kinder äh zu impfen. Also das das insofern äh ja.
Und das findet ihr jetzt im Prinzip statt ab dem siebten Juni.
Das ist also alles äh absolut in Ordnung. Ja.
Wir halten fest, also wenn Kinder unbedingt geimpft werden wollen und die Eltern damit einverstanden sind, also mit Kindern ist jetzt gemeint zwölf bis fünfzehn. Ja, also für sechzehn und siebzehn gilt das natürlich ganz genauso, aber die durften ja auch bisher schon.
Ja dann mach das. Dann tragt euch irgendwo äh eine Liste ein und dann dann werdet ihr die Gelegenheit bekommen. Wenn ihr noch nicht so richtig wisst und das irgendwie nicht unbedingt als erforderlich erachtet und die Kinder gesund sind, dann lasst erstmal sein.
Auch kein Problem. Ja, wenn es so eine Familie ist, wo ähm ja noch andere vulnerable,
Familienmitglieder sind, die vielleicht schon geimpft sind, aber wo man sich vielleicht auch nicht so sicher ist, wie stark die Impfung äh äh schützt, wie gut das Immunsystem da mitspielt. Und da laufen dann Kinder rum, die jetzt geimpft werden dürfen.
Nimmt sie doch einfach, dann äh seid ihr den Angriffsvektor äh vielleicht nicht los, aber dann ist der zumindest auch entsprechend reduziert. Also es ist so ein Abwägen. Und ich denke.
Mittelfristig, sicherlich werden dann mehr und mehr Kinder aus dieser Gruppe äh geimpft werden, wachsen ja auch am laufenden Hiter welche nach. Und ähm.
Wird sich das schon irgendwie ausgehen, aber es besteht da jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die Erforderlichkeit, da so einen Rush zu machen.
So impfen, ja, hast du noch was dazu.
Nee, ich fand äh nee, ich fand nur den tatsächlich den den Aspekt auch nochmal äh wichtig äh zu betonen, was du gerade gesagt hast, dass es auch
andere Gründe äh geben äh kann äh Kinder äh zu
zu impfen, nämlich um ältere äh zu schützen in in bestimmten Situationen, in bestimmten familiären Situationen oder Wohnsituationen, wo ja äh weil
was wir auch auch gehört haben, ist, dass verschiedene Leute genau vor dem Problem jetzt gerade stehen. Sie haben halt
Einfamilienmitglied, was halt ja irgendwie entweder vorerkrankt ist oder dann auch das Problem mit irgendwie schwanger
und äh schwanger werden ja bei uns
in der Regel nicht, nicht geimpft und wenn dann, was er sich noch ein anderes Kleinkind da ist und jetzt die Kitas demnächst wieder aufmachen, dann machen sich natürlich Leute Sorgen um äh wenn man zum Beispiel die, ja, die.
Ungeimpfte, Schwangere äh Mutter äh äh gerade im Zusammenhang mit einem Ungeimpften Kind, was dann demnächst in die Kita äh äh geht,
äh so. Und in solchen besonderen Situationen wär's natürlich auch ganz gut äh so, wenn es dafür dann Lösungen gäbe.
Ja bloß Kita-Kinder sind natürlich jetzt noch nicht äh dran.
Nee, aber äh in dem Fall, äh sozusagen ist es dann gucken, in Österreich werden zum Beispiel Schwangere geimpft, bei uns nicht.
Also da scheint sich die Fachwelt dann in den verschiedenen Ländern jetzt nicht nicht einig äh zu sein, wobei im Allgemeinen.
Wissens ja die meisten,
Impfungen bis auf äh Gelbfieber oder so, alle auch für Schwangere zugelassen sind und äh nur bei bei äh jetzt den Coronaimpfungen scheint man da gerade ein bisschen vorsichtig zu sein. Kann man natürlich auch verstehen, so spätestens seit dem Kontag gar einen Skandal oder so äh ist man bei Schwangeren, glaube ich,
auch übervorsichtig, so was Medikamente angeht und möglicherweise das Potenzial jetzt äh ja irgendwie den Fokus zu schädigen oder so.
Aber äh ja und ich meine, und ein letzten Punkt jetzt vielleicht noch, noch beim Impfen, wir hatten ja wir hatten ja immer.
Auch gesagt, na ja, wer sich wer sich irgendwie vor der Impfung äh äh fürchtet,
äh sollte mal das Virus ausprobieren oder eigentlich vor dem Virus äh impfen äh äh oder sich äh vor dem Virus fürchten, so.
Und genauso passt halt auch das Argument, was immer gerne gesagt wird, ah, die Impfstoffe sind halt super neu, wir wissen noch nichts über mögliche Langzeitschäden,
ne, wenn man dann auch antworten, ja, das Virus ist auch ziemlich neu und wir wissen noch nichts äh über Mögliche äh Langzeitschäden durch das Virus, aber.
Man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen
dass äh auch das Virus potentiell äh Langzeitschäden aller Art verursachen kann, auch wenn wahrscheinlich die meisten
auch Kinder sagen oder Erwachsenen sich.
Vollständig erholen, davon kann man auch ausgehen, wird aber gewissen Teil übrig bleiben. Hm der, ja
so wie es aussieht dann äh länger damit zu kämpfen hat mit der Infektion
oder also mit den mit den gesundheitlichen Schäden, gerade weil's eben auch potentiell so eine Multi
Organerkrankung ist und der Impfstoff halt alles angreift und ich vorstellen kann, dass das bestimmt auch nicht so geil ist, wenn so das Nervensystem angegriffen wird, während es sich gerade entwickelt oder so. Also das zumindest, also wenn ich vor irgendwas Angst
hätte dann eher davor äh oder vor Langzeitfolgen äh Angst hätte, dann eher vor den Langzeitfolgen
des Coronavirus äh auslösen kann und weniger vor den Langzeitfolgen, die jetzt,
ähm ja eine Impfung auslöst, wobei man das wiederum vor dem Hintergrund äh auch der Inzidenz sehen muss. Wenn wir es jetzt schaffen, die Insidenzen niedrig zu halten oder gar äh ja.
Das Ganze zum Stillstand zu bringen ist natürlich auch nicht so viel Druck da sich impfen zu lassen. Da kann man halt auch erstmal vielleicht noch ein bisschen abwarten und gucken
ob in anderen Ländern sich Nebenwirkungen wie bemerkbar äh machen noch, das wäre dann auch nicht völlig irrational, äh so etwas zu tun
aber äh bei, sagen, bei momentanen Inziden oder wenn's wieder in eine neue Welle äh reinläuft
äh und auf lange Sicht äh bleibt halt äh Kindern eh nur die Wahl, sich zu infizieren oder impfen zu lassen. Ja, eins eins von beiden wird
eintreten und äh da denke ich äh macht dann machen eben auch die Zahlen keinen Unterschied, ja, also weil klar, im Moment kann man auch sagen.
Bevor ich, wenn ich äh fünf Millionen Kinder.
Impfe ist das was anderes, als wenn ich jetzt fünf, wenn sich fünfzigtausend infizieren, dann bin ich halt auch ins Verhältnis setzen. Aber auf lange Sicht werden sich eben alle infizieren und dann
muss ich halt tatsächlich absolut vergleichen
Langzeitauswirkungen durchs Virus und mögliche Langzeitauswirkungen durch die Impfung äh von den ja die sich
zwar nicht ausschließen lassen, aber wo wir halt zumindest jetzt gesehen haben, dass das.
Ja, nicht, nichts, nicht signifikant zu sein scheint bisher. Ja.
Aber impfen ist Christenpflicht, wird äh der katholische Theologe Thomas Lemon äh vom Deutschlandfunk zitiert. Das äh.
Sozusagen jetzt äh sehr angemessen, weil man muss ja als Christ immer Gutes tun für die Gemeinschaft und das äh gehört das Impfen dann auch dazu. Das vielleicht mal noch so hintendran.
Falls jemand noch Zweifel gehabt hätte.
So, jetzt äh äh kommt die WHO äh ähm auf uns zu und sagt so, ja, hier ähm.
Gibt da ein Problem mit der Benennung all dieser ganzen Coronaviruse Varianten.
Wir haben uns da ja auch schon einen abgebrochen, weil da den Überblick zu behalten und immer zu wissen, was jetzt eigentlich genau gemeint ist. Ähm.
Schwierig, weil einerseits gibt's halt so dieses.
Orientierte, ja, also wir reden von der englischen Variante der südafrikanischen, brasilianischen und jetzt auch der indischen Variante. Ähm.
Das kriegt man irgendwie ganz gut rein, dann gibt's natürlich dann die äh Virologen und äh das Ganze medizinische Volk, den es ja nicht genau genug sein kann, weil das sind ja solche Bezeichnungen dann irgendwie ein bisschen zu diffus
äh halten sich dann eben schön an den Variantenbaum und zählen das irgendwie ordentlich durch.
Mit den Telefonnummern, hm oder IP-Adressen oder wie auch immer.
Mit den vielen Punkten, ne, wenn wir von B eins eins sieben sprechen, sprechen wir ja eigentlich von B Punkt eins, Punkt eins Punkt sieben. Und wenn wir von B eins, drei, fünf, eins sprechen, dann reden wir von B Punkt eins. Punkt drei, fünf eins.
Dreihunderteinundfünfzig.
Äh kriegt sich die dreihunderteinundfünfzig korrekt, genau und im Falle äh der indischen Variante reden wir von B Punkt eins Punkt sechshundertsiebzehn. Punkt zwei.
Ja, der Subtyp. Und um all das jetzt äh auseinanderzuhalten und vor allem auch von vornherein klarzumachen
wie man unterscheidet, nämlich zwischen den sogenannten
Varianz auf und in Varianz auf Konzern, also Interess ist so, aha, okay, da hat sich was herausgebildet, dass das setzt sich äh durch versus. Hier hat sich nicht nur irgendwas durchgesetzt, sondern.
Da sind wir auch besorgt, deswegen haben wir jetzt eine Variante auf Konzern. Ähm haben wir gesagt, okay, dann dann äh schaffen wir die Konfusion ab und schaffen sozusagen nochmal einen Namenslinie zusätzlich
ums äh komplett unübersichtlich zu machen und äh damit wir dann auch äh sagen wir mal so ein potenziellen ähm.
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht äh das als Rassismus bezeichnen, aber bestimmte Länder haben
offenbar auch ein Problem ihre Varianten, die sie gefunden haben zu melden, in der Angst dann weltweit mit Lindernamen zitiert zu werden. Da gab's ja auch ein paar schöne Tweets von irgendwelchen brexitnahen äh Briten,
die erst vor Monaten immer China war, Chinavarus
äh von sich gegeben haben, aber dann auf einmal total äh beklommen waren, dass total scheiße fanden, dass man jetzt von einem englischen Virus spricht.
Aber auch innerhalb von Großbritannien, ja, heißt ja, diese Variante kennt Virus, also.
Das ist dann da kloppen die sich dann sozusagen auf County-Ebene.
Genau.
Na ja, okay, jetzt soll das also alles mit dem griechischen Alphabet abgerockt werden und äh man spricht jetzt von den Varianten Alpha, Beta, Gamma und Delta,
in derselben Reihenfolge sind die englische, südafrikanische, brasilianische oder indische Variante oder äh für die Virologen unter uns B eins, eins, sieben, B eins drei fünf mit dreihunderteinundfünfzig, P eins und,
eins sechshundertsiebzehn Punkt zwei, ja.
Gemerkt, ganz einfach, oder? Und um die Konfusion komplett zu machen, die Varianz auf Konzern, äh Entschuldigung, die Varianz auf ähm Interesse.
Die werden auch mit den Buchstaben durchnummeriert, aber man fängt woanders an. Also es gibt da noch diese Variante Punkt eins der indischen Variante,
Und die heißt dann Kapha. Wobei, ich glaube, kein Mensch weiß, wie man bis Kapak kann irgendwie gar keiner mehr das griechische Alphabet durch äh buchstabieren.
Das wird äh noch interessant sein zu sehen, wie das so läuft und wie das so angenommen wird. Ähm ich bin gespannt.
Genau. Und wenn dann die nächste Variante aus dem Baskenland käme, würde das würde die sehr passend Etha heißen.
Ja. Ja und außerdem, ja genau, jetzt und jetzt äh ja und äh jetzt sind's halt äh also wenn jetzt dann jemand hat, dann die Griechen, genau und die Griechen sind jetzt an allem schuld.
Ja, ich glaube, die nehmen das eher locker in der Hinsicht. Äh solange man's nicht griechische Variante nennt.
Ja. Die ganzen griechischen Varianten, genau.
Welche griechische Variante hätten sie denn gern? Oh.
Ja. Mhm.
Gut, äh vielleicht noch mal ein Blick auf die Situation, wo jetzt gerade bei den äh bösen Varianten sind, weil wir haben ja allen eingangs der Sendung.
So ein tendenziellen Optimismus verbreitet. Ich will gar nicht äh zitiert werden, weil wir haben ja immer noch die Diskussion auch von der letzten Woche im äh Hinterkopf,
so ganz raus sind wir noch nicht aus dem ganzen Spaß und das kann man halt sehr schön sehen an UK. Dort ist nämlich jetzt die offizielle Insidenz.
Zumindest nominell über der von Deutschland. Jetzt ist natürlich so.
Du hast es vorhin ja auch schon erwähnt, da wird viel getestet und die haben eine Positivquote von null Komma fünf Prozent. Ja, Vergleiche, wir sind jetzt bei.
Was war für eins angekommen.
'ne fünf fünf irgendwas waren das doch oder?
Wo waren wir? Wir waren bei vier Komma eins sechs.
Ah, okay, sorry, ja.
Komma eins sechs, also viel besser, aber immerhin nochmal das Achtfache von dem, was äh UK jetzt am Start hat.
Sprich, man kann davon ausgehen, dass tatsächlich die Inzidenz äh in UK doch noch unter der liegt in Deutschland. Aber sie steigt und sie steigt wegen.
Wegen ja wegen Delta.
Wegen der indischen Variante verdammt. Und ähm weil die wird da eingetragen ähm na ja.
Inder oder Leute, die nach Indien reisen und wieder zurückkommen? Klar, Großbritannien und Indien haben natürlich ganz anderen Link als äh Deutschland zum Beispiel
und ähm derzeit sind diese Zahlen auch noch extrem lokal unterschiedlich. Also es gibt einfach bestimmte Communitys, da ist es dann eben extrem. Aber das ist ja auch genau das Problem
Das heißt, überall, wo diese Variante.
Sich etwas hat verbreiten können, tut sie das dann eben nochmal schneller als die Kent-Variante und also.
Alpha, ja.
Alpha, mhm.
Oh Mann. Und dementsprechend,
ist jetzt die äh das Datum, der einundzwanzigste Sechste ein wenig in Gefahr, wo die britische Regierung davon geträumt hat, doch alle Maßnahmen fallen zu lassen, weil es ja so gut läuft,
Kurz nochmal ein Vergleich, also UK hat im Bereich der Erstimpfung eine Zahl von achtundfünfzig Komma sieben Prozent.
Das ist ungefähr das eins Komma dreifache von Deutschland, was wir vorhin genannt hatten, ne. Also sie sind uns quasi auch nur noch so um
dreißig Prozent voraus. Allerdings bei der Vollimpfung, das hatte ich, glaube ich, schon erwähnt, sind sie irgendwie doppelt so weit. Also sie haben knapp vierzig Prozent ähm vollständig Geimpfte und wir sind ja bei zwanzig,
Ja und das ähm könnte uns natürlich dann auch blühen.
Also wenn's in irgendeiner Form zum Eintrag kommt und es muss halt jetzt nicht mit Indien Reisenden geschehen, sondern da reicht's einfach, dass man Briten trifft auf,
Urlaub oder halt nach Großbritannien fährt, in den Urlaub, sich dort äh.
Diese Variante äh eintritt und dann wieder nach Deutschland einschleppt.
Alles jetzt keine besonders unrealistischen Szenarien, dann könnte es halt sehr schnell auch anders aussehen. Also mit anderen Worten sollten darauf gefasst sein.
Dass na ja, also ich glaube, der Juli.
Wird mindestens glimpflich ablaufen, aber ich wäre halt sehr froh, wenn wir es im Juli noch schaffen, bei fallenden Zahlen zu bleiben. Weil wenn man das nicht tun.
Dann haben wir halt genau wieder das nächste Problem äh an der Backe und wenn wir diese Variante nicht in den Griff äh halten können durch viel Impfung und.
Auch beibehalten von bestimmten Maßnahmen. Dann, ja, weiß ich auch nicht, dann könnte der Herbst schon wieder ungemütlich werden und da habe ich, ehrlich gesagt, nicht so richtig.
Ja ähm plus äh so als ja hier schöne Tabelle, die wahrscheinlich auch in die.
Shownotes äh dann kommt, die so die verschiedenen Varianten auf Übertragbarkeit äh dann äh Immun, also wie.
Wie stark unseren äh sagen
Reinfektionen äh möglich sind und wie gut dann die Impfstoffe eigentlich helfen, wobei sie da bei den Impfstoffen überall einen Haken dahinter äh.
Haben. Was halt bedeutet ja, äh Impfungen helfen grundsätzlich gegen alle Varianten.
Aber so als im im im Kleingedruckten steht äh dann hm.
So, dass eben doch auch alle Impfstoffe zwar wirksam sind, aber ähm
eben es Unterschiede gibt und insbesondere, dass bei einigen Varianten eben die zweite Dosis äh sehr, sehr
wichtig ist und vor allem auch bei äh der ja indischen Delta-Variante
ist es wohl so, dass die erste Dosis, ganz egal, ob das jetzt MRNA oder Astrasinika ist
verhindert halt nur zu dreißig Prozent eine Infektion jetzt. Ja was halt zwar trotzdem heißt, dass sie halt schwere Erkrankungen und äh äh Todesfälle sehr gut
hm reduziert aber eben weniger, ja?
Und äh ja, von daher wie gesagt äh könnte eben Probleme in England dann auch auch äh daran liegen
Ja, dass dass dort eben gerade noch noch sehr viele Leute nicht zwei,
geimpft sind. So und äh dass der Virus nach wie vor genug äh anfällige äh.
Wirte in der Bevölkerung dann dann findet. Und,
halt auch noch nicht, ob wir schon das Ende der Fahnenstange äh erreicht haben, was so die Varianten äh angeht. Und gerade jetzt nochmal die die indische Delta-Variante scheint äh eben,
B eins, eins, sieben, die Alpha-Variante äh.
Ja nochmal an äh Übertragbarkeit äh zu übertreffen. Die ist da so mit mit vier Plus äh gekennzeichnet, äh während äh ja.
Sieben kennt Alpha äh nur drei Plusse hat und die anderen Varianten nur ein oder zwei.
Und,
was so die Variante mit eben dem größten Immun-Escape zu sein scheint es halt Südafrika B dreizehn einundfünfzig.
Glaube ich, oder? Nachgucken, ja.
Ich sehe auch gerade, es gibt schon eine neuere Variante hier von dieser Grafik äh mit mit den ganzen Bezeichnungen. Äh kannst du gleich nochmal rausklicken. Die zweite Variante.
Musste diese ähm Gedankenleistung nicht selber.
Na ja. IC. Ja, jetzt äh.
Gibt's auch schon Epsilon und das wird alles wunderbar unübersichtlich. Ich fand die Zahlen irgendwie besser.
Plus, dass es Vermutungen gibt, äh,
dass äh jetzt auch eben die Delta-Variante sehe ich gerade in der neuen Tabelle äh dass die halt möglicherweise, es ist noch nicht ganz sicher äh immun,
Escape ähm zu äh identisch mit der Beta-Variante sein könnte. Alles nicht,
nicht ganz so schön. Äh ja, was.
Aber das Positive, was man eigentlich festhalten kann, bei den Varianten, die jetzt da sind, äh wirkt halt,
die Impfung ähm trotzdem oder es gibt Impfungen, die halt äh äh auch sehr gut wirken gegen die Varianten, aber eben nicht gleich gut gegen alle Varianten.
Gut. Ähm was haben wir noch? Wir haben sonst noch äh leicht.
Ja. Weiß noch nicht. Also ist noch nicht beunruhigend, würde ich sagen.
Es gibt jetzt äh erste Berichte aus Israel, da schaut man sich natürlich jetzt die Auswirkungen der durchgehenden Biontech-Impfung in dem Land äh genauer an
versucht halt in den Daten irgendwas zu finden. Das ist jetzt noch so ein bisschen ähm vorab, aber ich dachte, weil da eh schon drüber berichtet wird, können wir das hier auch nochmal mit reinnehmen,
nämlich so einen leichten Verdacht auf eine mögliche Auswirkung auf Herzmuskelentzündungen.
Oder wie das so schön äh auf medizinisch heißt, Mio, Carditis.
Das ist so etwas, was bei äh gesunden, jüngeren Leuten äh auftreten kann und so ein bisschen auch so ein Erklärungsmuster ist, zum Beispiel für äh plötzliches Herzversagen bei Sportlern, was man so äh kennt. Da gibt's immer mal wieder so Leute, die einfach so.
Fußballplatz umfallen und so weiter, die voll durchtrainiert sind. Und da ist dann eben so eine ähm so eine so eine Entzündung der Herzmuskeln, ähm so ein bisschen im Verdacht da
Auslöser zu sein und sowas ist jetzt in leicht gehäuftem Falle auch
Geimpften gefunden worden. Ähm es gibt da insgesamt so hundertachtundvierzig Fälle, die man sich derzeit anschaut, betrifft im wesentlichen junge Männer interessanterweise. Zwischen äh ich glaube sechzehn und vierundzwanzig,
und ähm gut sechzehn heißt halt, äh drunter wurde ja eh nicht geimpft, von daher ist klar, dass das so ein bisschen die Untergrenze ist. Ähm.
Gab wohl auch noch zwei Todesfälle, aber da ist wohl irgendwie überhaupt nicht klar, ob das überhaupt mit der Impfung jetzt in Verbindung gebracht werden kann, tendenziell eher nicht,
Ja und das ist so in Untersuchung, also da ist noch überhaupt gar kein Grund zur Panik und ähm das äh Paul-Ehrlich-Institut bereitet wohl einen Bericht nächste Woche vor
Wie die das so sehen mit den Daten in Deutschland. Ähm
ja gut, Vorsicht ist sicherlich generell geboten, aber hier muss man jetzt noch nicht gleich durchdrehen. Also das ist doch überhaupt nichts belegt.
Was mir halt auch viel äh so als erstes, als ich das gelesen hatte, war.
Ähm das ist ja auch ein Problem, was grundsätzlich äh bei allen Arten von äh Virus.
Infektionen äh auftritt, also es ist ja ist eine bekannte Gefahr, insbesondere, wenn man halt ähm irgendwie.
Infiziert ist und dann intensiv Sport betreibt. So.
Dann äh ja kann sich das eben ja zu einer Herzmuskelentzündung äh führen. Da gab's auch ein paar Prominente,
Fälle Geißler oder so sogar der davon betroffen war.
Ähm ja und ähm in dem Zusammenhang wär's vielleicht dann nochmal wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen
dass man grundsätzlich nach einer Impfung auch einfach sich mal mit körperlichen Aktivitäten zurückhalten sollte, genau aus aus dem Grund.
Auch weil äh ja äh sollte man halt nicht nicht tun, so nach direkt nach der Impfung dann am besten irgendwie sein Marathontraining äh.
Zwar aussetzen für zwei Wochen so.
Denke ich ist unabhängig von dieser Meldung jetzt glaube ich grundsätzlich eine eine
eine gute Empfehlung bei allen Impfungen äh um eben die Möglichkeit von von Impfschäden äh zu reduzieren, ja.
Ähm aber ich denke, wir bleiben da weiter am am Ball im Moment ist es noch nicht noch nicht ganz so klar und ich sage mal, ja, hundertvierunddreißig Fälle.
Hundertachtundvierzig.
Achtundvierzig Fälle und eben zwei Todesfälle von denen unklar ist, ob sie überhaupt.
Im Zusammenhang mit der Herzmuskelentzündung stehenden. Also auch jetzt keine Zahlen, wo man jetzt in Panik äh verfallen müsste.
Genau. Ja.
Da wir uns dem äh Ende der Sendung nähern, müssen wir jetzt langsam zu den guten Nachrichten kommen. Also nicht, dass wir nicht schon gute Nachrichten hatten, aber das fand ich nochmal eine besonders gute Nachricht,
allerdings bezieht sich das auf die USA, wo das äh beobachtet wurde, ob wir schon auf ähnliche Zahlen hier kommen können, weiß ich nicht. Aber wir hatten das ja auch schon mal, dass auch in Deutschland,
durch die ganzen Corona-Maßnahmen im letzten Jahr bestimmte Infektionskrankheiten,
irgendwie gar nicht mehr so richtig gesehen werden. Alles geht zurück, Masern, Grippe, pipapo.
Und den USA habe ich jetzt einen Bericht gefunden, wo.
Na ja, nicht nur berichtet wird, dass die Grippezahl zurückgehen. Das wäre ja jetzt gar keine besondere.
Nachricht wert, sondern dass durch die niedrigen Zahlen, also sich das Tragen von Masten durch Abstand und so weiter nicht nur weniger Grippe unterwegs ist, nein ähm.
Es sieht so aus, als ob äh durch diese Maßnahmen auch bestimmte Subtypen aussterben.
Und das hat eine interessante Implikation. Also diese ganze Influenza-Welt ist recht komplex und die durchdringe ich auch nur bedingt. Aber es gibt äh ähm unter anderem diesen H3.
N2 äh Influenza äh Stamm.
Des Influenza A Virus, also das ist da auch alles irgendwie noch mal tausendfach untergruppiert und hm es hat sich.
Zwanzig zwölf so ein bisschen abgezeichnet, dass ähm sich Influenza B, also in diesem H3, N zwei äh Sub-Typ sich komisch entwickelt hat,
und zwar dahingehend, dass eben diese Mutation sich nochmal in so Untergruppen,
genannt wird das dann kladen, aufgeteilt haben und.
Das machte es generell schwieriger, diesen Grippeimpfstoff, den jährlichen, anzupassen, weil man nicht so richtig wusste, welche dieser Kladen letzten Endes dominant werden würde.
Und das hat dann so diesen Effekt, dass man man muss sich da in gewisser Hinsicht äh entscheiden. Bei dem, bei der Anpassung des Kripo-Impfstoffs, ob man jetzt mehr auf die eine oder auf die andere Klage geht und wenn man da nicht die Richtige trifft,
dann gibt man der Anderen zu viel Raum und die setzt sich dann äh deutlich durch und dann hilft der Impfstoff nicht.
Also es gab's wohl schon zwanzig siebzehn, also nach so fünf Jahren der Entwicklung, da ist der Impfstoff halt,
in die eine Richtung hin designt worden, weil das ist ja immer so ein so ein so eine Wette auf die Zukunft in gewisser Hinsicht. Und es führte dann dazu, dass um die dreiviertel der Geimpften überhaupt gar keinen richtigen Schutz hat, weil halt einfach ein anderer Sub-Typ sich durchgesetzt hat.
Ja und das Tragen von Masten hat jetzt wohl eine dieser H3N zwei Klagen und ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht, wie viele es gibt. Es gibt ja Artikel nicht her, äh komplett gekillt hat.
So und ähm auch bei äh einer von zwei Linien beim Influenza B Virus mit dem Namen keine Ahnung, wie das alles wieder was da noch für Untergliederungen
und ähm namens Bereiche äh gibt, die muss wohl auch dran glauben. Beide Versionen wurden irgendwie seit einem Jahr nicht mehr gesehen.
Und das ja, das ist irgendwie eine ganz gute Nachricht, weil das halt unter Umständen das Design vom Grippeimpfstoff einfacher macht.
Also wir haben quasi Varianz aus dem aus dem Gesamtvirus geschehen der Influenza,
rausgenommen oder zumindest ist das jetzt in den USA gesehen worden, inwiefern das hier gilt, müssen wir erst nochmal sehen, aber ist natürlich nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich, dass wir auch ähnliche Effekte hier beobachten können.
Da zeigt sich mal wieder schön, was es auch noch so für positive Auswirkungen äh der ganzen Pandemie gibt. Ja, man muss das das Schöne.
An der Pandemie sehen. Darum geht's doch jetzt eigentlich. Und das ist irgendwie so eine dieser schönen Sachen.
Ja, also.
Hey, definitiv. Wir hatten ja geguckt, dass das wirklich viele andere Viren äh jetzt im Rahmen.
Ja eben dieser Kollateralschäden gewissermaßen unserer unserer Maßnahmen sind
und äh ja, wir äh dort, weil sie extreme Einbrüche auch gesehen haben bei bei verschiedenen,
Virustypen so. Äh bei Reino Viren auch, also äh schon der der gewöhnliche Schnupfen sozusagen.
Und ja also ich gucke mir gerade hier an.
So den den Verlauf an ja.
Es ist respektorische Syncidalviren RSV Humane Metabne und reinovieren. So.
Und ja plus dann eben Influenza Viren die sehen also.
Insbesondere die der die armen Schnupfen äh Viren sind äh irgendwie ganz schön unter die Räder gekommen.
Zeit für unser Fazit, Pavel.
Ja also Fazit ist,
die Zahlen sinken, das ist erfreulich. Äh sie.
Sinken nicht ganz so stark wie letzte Woche. Das ist weniger erfreulich, aber äh,
das kann eben auch andere äh Gründe haben, also noch, noch gibt's da keinen Grund äh zur Beunruhigung, also alles.
Im Grunde genommen, solange der R-Wert unter eins bleibt, hm äh ist es okay, wobei,
jetzt in die Phase natürlich auch kommen, wo es auf der einen Seite ähm
wir zunehmend Coronafreie Landkreise kriegen werden, aber wir haben auch noch äh immer, muss man sagen, immer noch äh hochinzidenz,
Landkreise.
So, die man dann, äh, auf die man besonders, äh, auf, äh, passen muss, aber ganz.
Unter dem Strich äh zumindest äh haben uns die Lockerungen äh.
Jetzt noch keine Explosion der Zahlen beschert und es gibt.
Noch Hoffnung, dass hm ja.
Äh das eine vierte Welle ausbleiben könnte oder zumindest äh nicht.
So schlimm ausfallen könnte, wenn wir dem dann dann rechtzeitig entgegensteuern. Ich denke, wir können uns.
Jetzt aber zurecht ein bisschen drauf freuen äh,
ja jetzt aus dem aus dem Lockdown wieder rauszukommen, aber Vorsicht ist nach wie vor geboten. Ähm so sehe ich,
gerade den, den Ausblick, also wir sollten's jetzt auch nicht übertreiben. Ähm mit äh ja.
Dem, äh, was, was wir tun. Und ich denke, das wird bei vielen auch auch erstmal so so bleiben und zumindest,
Für Deutschland gibt's jetzt noch keinen Wegfall
aller Maßnahmen, glaube ich, der der terminiert ist, sondern da wird jetzt auch erstmal teilweise geguckt und und gewartet, äh wie wirken sich jetzt die bisherigen Lockerungen dann aus und.
Da können wir ja erste Effekte sehen, müssten wir halt schon schon sehen, aber die,
fallen halt noch moderat aus, sodass ich, dass ich eine gewisse Hoffnung habe, ähm dass das jetzt erstmal äh so weitergeht.
Befürchtungen bisschen, ja, langfristig Varianten nach wie vor äh sind so ein bisschen.
Quasi nicht der Silberstreif, sondern das sind die ja grauen Gewitterwolken, die da irgendwo in der in der Ferne sind so mit einem,
was aus dem Ausland rüberkommt aber ja hoffen wir dass das dass das Gewitter vielleicht an uns vorbeiziehen.
Also noch noch habe ich Hoffnung.
Genau und ähnlich ist es ja auch an der Impffront. Also hier.
Werden die nächsten zwei Wochen noch ein bisschen dünne sein für Leute, die jetzt noch auf eine Erstimpfung warten, aber die Zahlen werden dann gegen Ende des Monats deutlich anziehen.
Ich rechne damit, dass wir äh spätestens ab Mitte Juni da eine spürbare Achseleration äh sehen werden
und ähm ja, ich hoffe
Das wäre dann, ich hab's jetzt nicht äh so richtig ausgerechnet, will jetzt eigentlich auch gar keine Voraussage machen, aber ist dann schon, kann schon sein, dass wir
ähm ein paar andere Länder wieder eingeholt haben, die vorangegangen sind, ne, weil die ja auch grade nicht so viel Wachstumspotential haben. Ich hatte zum Beispiel, glaube ich, in der letzten,
oder bei der vorletzten Sendung, hatte ich ja mal so ein bisschen so meine meine Beunruhigung geteilt, sodass es ja in Israel gar nicht so richtig weitergeht und die so bei sechzig Prozent feststecken.
Ha. Typisches Beispiel fand ich richtig nachgedacht. Ist halt auch eine extrem junge Bevölkerung.
Und tatsächlich machen halt die äh unter Sechzehnjährigen.
Auch ähm glaube ich fünfundzwanzig Prozent außerhalb dieser Zeit sind wir ganz parat. Da sind dann oder fast dreißig Prozent, glaube ich, sogar, ja, das heißt, da ist dann auch gar nicht mehr so viel Luft, sprich.
Sehr viele Leute haben da auch schon tatsächlich die Impfung in Anspruch
genommen. In Deutschland haben wir natürlich ein sehr viel geringeren jungen Anteil. Dementsprechend gehe ich mal davon aus, dass wir schon das Potenzial haben so Ende Juni so uns den, den sechzig Prozent zu nähern.
Zumindest mal erst geimpft sind und die Zweitimpfung werden jetzt auch kräftig anziehen.
Und ja und dann ansonsten so einfach mal europäischen.
Durchguckt, was wir noch nicht, was wir jetzt nicht gemacht hatten, immer auch sagen äh.
Bis auf UK hm.
Steigen die Zahlen nirgendwo so so richtig insbesondere also weil Frankreich sinken die Zahlen.
So äh ja Spanien auch immer noch zwar langsamer, Schweiz gehen sie weiter runter ähm ja hm.
Man noch äh in den USA interessanterweise auch Italien sinkt, Österreich sinkt. Tschechien ist auch ziemlich weit.
Jetzt mit den, den Zahlen, trotz.
Großen Testregimes, ja, Finnland sowieso, sogar auch, ich meine, Polen äh ist auch ganz.
Ganz äh weit unten. Also hm.
Allzu viele Warnsignale äh gibt es äh bisher nicht und es scheint auch kein Land zu geben, was jetzt seit Beginn der der.
Impfkampagne oder oder nachdem sich, sage mal, so eine, ja, signifikanter Teil der Bevölkerung geimpft wurde, ist kein Land jetzt in eine in eine wirklich große neue Welle rein
gegangen und äh,
und da sind uns ja einige sind uns ja Impf und Lockerungstechnisch voraus und aus aus der Richtung ist halt noch nichts zu sehen und England,
oder UK könnte halt deswegen ein Sonderfall sein, weil die mittlerweile über.
Fünfzig Prozent Deltavariante haben, wir sind irgendwie noch einstellig, was die indische Deltavariante äh angeht, äh so dass wir auf jeden Fall,
ein bisschen Zeit haben und das äh sicherlich noch ich sage mal zwei Monate dauern dürfte, bis diese Variante bei uns so die fünfzig Prozent.
Überschreitet, wenn sie es denn äh überschreitet. Anderer Vorteil, wenn wir jetzt eine Niedriginzidenzphase.
Reinlaufen ist, äh dass äh man sich dann gezielter ähm,
dem Ganzen widmen kann und äh dass es dann eben auch mehr Gegenden gibt, wo schlicht kein Virus ist und wo kein Virus ist, da kann sich auch erstmal niemand anstecken so.
Genau.
Ja. Also äh insofern ja wünsche ich
jedem äh nur, dass äh er äh in seinem Landkreis das aus seinem Landkreis der Virus so bald wie möglich verschwindet und ja, ansonsten
scheint sich so für zukünftige Pandemien scheint zumindest,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen äh schlichtweg Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gewisse,
Vorteile zu haben, also wenn die zombieapokalypse kommt oder so, ist es da vielleicht.
Verteilen. Genau, alle nach Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, da sind die Inzidenzen ganz niedrig. Stecken wir alle an jetzt.
Gut, machen wir Schluss, oder?
Ja
Super. Okay, das war's äh von uns und ähm wir hören uns dann nächste Woche wieder und Dienstag natürlich auch wieder unsere kleine Feedback-Runde auf Clubhaus und ja, ansonsten bereitet schon mal euren äh Urlaub vor, übertreibt's nicht und äh.
Impftermine, wenn ihr noch keine habt, weil da gibt's jetzt demnächst äh ganz viele. Ja, wir sagen tschüss und bis.